Are we on the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by on it dot.
Look at that mother fucker.
Got a new way of doing it on this though.
I'm not,
I'm not down with windows yet.
Dude,
I'm still confused.
We're brought to you by [inaudible] dot com if you go to on it,
that's o n n I t.com.
You will see that,
uh,
not only do we have the supplements that we've always had in,
but now we have kettle bells and battle ropes.
Uh,
so if you want to be all manly like Tito Ortiz,
get your swole on Sun.
Uh,
what are kettlebells is a long conversation.
Folks,
if you're not familiar with the exercise,
I suggest first of all,
go get yourself a personal training before you start slinging around cannon
balls because,
uh,
it gets complicated and you could hit yourself in the head and people have died,
I'm sure anyway.
And people have died from weaver emotes.
Well,
yeah,
they have,
right?
How many people have died from,
we can promote flying off into capitalism.
It's been a few,
right?
People probably have died,
I know people have died from coconuts.
I know 150 people die every year because of coconuts.
Coconuts fall hit you in the head and you're dead.
One 50 a year.
Oh,
you can multiply cook and I buy like 10 years.
She get that and Kettle Bell,
right?
Yeah,
probably.
You got to think all these fucking idiots.
Think about all the knuckleheads you see at the gym.
All right?
Don't be that guy.
First of all,
if you're,
if you're really interested in it,
I suggest start off very light.
There's a workout that I do call the extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
35 pound kettle bell.
That's it.
It seems like nothing,
but I'm telling you,
if you do all the exercises in that DVD will fucking kick your ass.
I 35 out care.
Well,
we'll kick it will kick your ass is crazy,
right?
Sure.
I worked out with them.
They actually will kick some ass.
Yeah.
Tito motherfucking Ortiz.
Okay.
The longest reigning UFC light heavyweight champion ever working out with a 35
pound Kettlebell.
It's that ridiculous.
It gives you functional strength.
And unlike,
um,
look,
any lifting weights,
we'll get you stronger.
It's a real simple pick things up.
Your,
your body will respond,
you will get stronger.
It's a very simple,
but in order to maximize your time,
there's two beautiful things about kettlebells.
One of them is that it uses your whole body as one unit by slinging these kettle
bells around.
You have to concentrate in your posture.
You have to tighten up your core,
you have to cut you off,
you,
yours and your legs.
He using your back using all of it together as one big unit and instead of like
curls or tricep extensions,
then that shit will make you stronger.
But as far as something that's going to be able to apply directly in Catholics,
I think kettlebells or one of the best things you can ever do,
and if you wanted to pick out one way to work out,
that's one of them.
Um,
it's,
it's one of the best ones.
Olympic lift weights,
that's good too.
You know,
cleans and presses and shit like that.
It's just you want to use your whole body as one unit.
If you're interested in Kettlebells,
we sell the best quality Troy cattle bells that you can fucking buy.
They're the perfect cattle bell.
They will be here long after you're dead.
They will find them when there's archeologists from the future who don't even
use words anymore and communicate with telekinesis and they're digging up holes
where human society in 2012 used to be,
they'll fund is fucking cannon ball with a handle on and go one.
If I lead their pyramid,
it'll be those,
uh,
those,
yeah,
my old old mech heads that they find in Peru,
they don't know what the fuck they are,
you know?
Um,
so,
uh,
go and check all that shit out.
Alpha brain of course is the number one supplement that we have still.
Uh,
if you're,
if you're interested in any of that stuff as well,
I always suggest you gotta Google it.
You got to be educated on anything you're taking.
Is that Alpha brain.
Oh,
that's good to,
uh,
what does knew mood knew ladies?
I have five HTP and l Tryptofan uh,
enhance her.
What it is,
is when you take five HTP at your brain produces more serotonin,
and when you take a l Tryptofan l trip,
defend converts in your body to five HTP,
which converts a Serotonin.
It's like a multistep process for the two different nutrients.
So it almost acts as like a time release,
sort of an effect.
Uh,
but if you're interested in five HTP,
a very important thing,
make sure you're not an SSRI.
Noah antidepressants,
no.
Is that the right way to say it?
SSL,
whenever there's certain certain Antique Cfi,
CSI Vegas,
there's certain antidepressants that uh,
what,
uh,
what they're exactly doing is the same thing that five HTP is doing.
They're elevating your serotonin.
So if you're taking that,
you might be taking too much.
If you take both of them the same time,
uh,
talk to doctor bitch,
what am I a doctor?
Go to go to on a.com.
Use the word Rogan.
The Codeword Rogan save 10% off of any of the supplements and a battle ropes and
kettlebells.
We're selling them literally as cheap as humanly possible.
The battle ropes.
You cannot find them better quality or anywhere else on the Internet there.
That's as cheap as you're going to find.
They're the best.
They're big fat ones and they're like,
hold them out.
Do a giant elephant.
That's what she said.
Tito Ortiz,
ladies and gentlemen.
All right.
Kill the Cuban music.
Brian.
Let's get crazy
experience
trying my day.
Powerful Tito Ortiz,
ladies and gentlemen,
right when a Alienware keeps trying to get me to upgrade,
bitch,
I ain't upgrade and update your software.
Uh,
alien re spawn.
We should just wipe all of that.
Why it maybe maybe supposed to it when they're sort of helping us out.
Dude.
First of all,
thanks for doing the podcast man.
Appreciate it.
Appreciate it man.
This is cool.
I think the fans would dig it too.
So yeah,
I'm wearing social media.
[inaudible] athletics since what 99 is that when you started this sampling
Goddamn businessman athlete?
Is that the focus now?
Now that you're,
you're completely done fighting.
They're going to always be up on my clothing companies.
Always my focus,
my love.
You know,
I,
I have love for something that I've never want to get rid of people who tried to
come in and buy me out and I'd never wanted to sell out,
you know,
cause it represents something to you,
your baby,
you made it,
you know,
and it's punishment.
I mean,
every person who goes through work deals with some type of punishment,
you know,
either you wake up at five in the morning and you press the alarm clock going,
God,
what am I doing this for?
Like,
and realize you got to pay bills,
you got to take care of your family.
It's a punishment.
And that's what all life and of life go through
his punishment.
That's what my brand represents.
You,
uh,
you told me something once we're talking about submissions and uh,
you said,
you know the problem with submitting a guy as you could submit the guy and after
he taps,
he's okay.
And he's like,
Yo man,
he got lucky man.
He got lucky.
But when I get on top of you and punch you in the fucking head for 15 minutes,
I'm punished until the referee pulls me up.
That is punishment.
And I'll never forget that because that really,
uh,
that,
that one quote really embodied your career,
you know,
I mean,
you only submitted Yuki Kondo and Ryan Bader,
those the only two guys.
Right.
That's it.
And then my man,
that's it.
That's all I've ever done.
I just want to put on a show,
man.
I,
you know,
I thought it was,
those guys are going on and he caught me
lucky with the arm triangle or with the arm bar.
I mean,
don't get me wrong.
I would love to submit it.
Machida,
that would have been awesome.
But I always wanted to be dominating and be on top.
It just polarize a guy just to try to finish them and you know,
make them not want to find me again.
Do Yuki Kondo one was the all elusive one arm Ghia teen.
She called a Cobra Choke Colbert show.
That's from cal State Bakersfield.
I said a one arm,
one arm was grabbing his chin where I do,
unless I'm hooking the Chin and I tried to pin his chin across to his shoulder
and it's almost like a throat choke.
Cal State Bakersfield to cook.
Daryl pope showed us that chuck and we'd choke guys unconscious in wrestling
matches and the refugees don't know what's happening because in college you're
allowed to turn in the chin wherever you want it.
In high school rules,
you're not allowed to church,
turn the Gen wherever you want.
But I learned that and I do it a lot of Jujitsu guys because they'd pull guard,
they watch the guy,
my chin under my arm,
I'm fine.
But once you hook and kind of snuggle in,
guys don't go anywhere.
And this is one of those old school catch wrestling moves.
Exactly.
There's a,
is that the same one that Jake Shield used our Nick Thompson in strike force and
hit him with some sort of a one arm one and he posted out with his left arm and
then he arches back.
It was pretty gnarly.
Yeah.
It's a little different cause that's for this one.
You got to hook literally outside hit.
You didn't hook the outside hip to make it happen and you hook the hip and we do
as you're compressing the lungs and a compression to the chin and the neck of
the same time,
so it's like a compressive choke,
is it?
The hardest thing is to me seems as an observer watching it seemed it's hard for
dudes to put new aspects to the game once they become successful.
That seems to be the most hard,
but I think that the hardest thing is,
is doing it in repetition because everything you got to do in repetition to get
better and better,
you have to do it in repetition over and over again.
Guys think,
well,
okay,
I know that move.
I don't need to do that anymore.
No,
you,
you'll lose it during going live and wrestling.
That I learned was I would do it so much I was reaction.
It wasn't a factor of just doing it to do it.
You did it as reaction and so when I would go for a high crotch guy would defend
that.
They got to go to a single guide defending that.
I go to a double guy,
defend that I'd go back to a high crotch and he's not even thinking chaining
them together because that's how you've drilled it and chain wrestling.
Exactly.
That's what it came into fighting the same thing,
but you kind of get caught up and to the of going to,
well I'm going to do submission defenses.
That was my first thing.
I didn't want to learn submissions because I wanted all the defenses first and
then I learned all the defenses and I was like,
okay,
I'm not going to get cotton anymore.
Then I started learning offenses.
Then after certain learn offenses,
okay great,
and now I got this position is good.
Then I started learning more standup and then it was just,
it was Kinda like a,
I didn't want to over step my boundaries by doing too much at once,
so I just kind of putting a little,
I guess little schedules.
It was like,
all right,
this week I'll work on this,
next week I'll work on this.
And then I had to go back to the first week,
a couple of months later.
So it's like,
yeah,
it's hard to absorb something new.
Also,
especially if you're trying to do like two different things new.
Because when you,
when you absorb something new,
it becomes like an obsession where like thinking about it,
you'll go back grounds.
Well you'll go for that move over and over and over and over and over and over
again.
I mean,
when I was in high school and then I was known for a head and arm and a low
single,
I mean that was,
people go,
you tie up with them,
he's gonna hit an arm,
throw you,
you stand away from me.
He's listening to you.
And I was known for that.
But then when I got it to be a junior,
junior and senior in high school,
part Herrera was my coach who fought in the UFC.
He goes,
Tito,
you're going to live by that.
You're going to die by that.
Let's learn.
High crotch lists are in double like lister and snap down.
And I started learning these different things and collegiate wrestling that I
was like,
oh,
I'm starting to learn all this different stuff.
So I wasn't just stuck to one thing.
Yeah,
it's funny when you see a guy like Cody McKenzie,
you know,
has got this fucking ridiculous guillotine that nobody can run away from.
But it's,
it's so weird to have one move like that.
But someone will learn the defense too.
I mean,
you look at,
uh,
who was it?
Um,
GAF from strike.
I start versus from pride.
Who came over here?
The heavyweight Nogueira now the,
now the [inaudible],
the big guy who just got burnt out on all the vitamin him got out.
I can't think of,
he got burnt for steroids.
Carlin,
Bob.
No.
Carwyn was never a proud guy.
No,
I over him over him.
He had a sick amount of guillotines.
He caught Belfort with them over and over and over.
Then all of a sudden he got away from it.
It's not pretty much got away from the ground game period when he became a k one
grand Prix champion.
And just to,
to clarify,
you didn't get really get popped for steroids to get popped for elevated
elevated testosterone to epitestosterone ratio.
It's from testosterone.
I mean he admitted they shot him with testosterone.
Um,
yeah,
he was a really trying to concentrate entirely on the kickboxing for awhile.
You know,
when you see a guy that,
I mean he's one of the,
like the best examples ever of a guy whose career was in the shitter and then
pull out of it and all of a sudden he's on top of the world and amazing did it.
He's good.
He's great.
And I mean Anderson Silva,
Anderson Silva,
when he was in pride and he was losing and getting submitted and all of a sudden
he came in to Casi submitted them and they came over to UFC and just hasn't been
beaten since I don't think.
Yeah.
It's interesting when you see guys,
when you catch guys like in between camps and you know there's a split when it
can't you.
That's when you really realize like how important it is to have the whole
fucking package together.
To have a coach that you will listen to,
to have trainers who were looking out for you to have a guy who's actually
analyzing your training and say,
you know,
he's,
he looks like he's peeking a little early.
We've got to take them back little,
let's check his heart rate guys who are really looking at you like a race horse.
And when a guy doesn't have that,
like Anderson Silva went for a stretch in pride where he'd left,
who'd Jamar and,
uh,
formed Moitai Dream Team and he sewed on his own for a little bit too.
And it was losing man.
It wasn't the same dude,
just wasn't the same guy.
And then he's trying to sell it.
The great people in any look at.
He does an awesome job.
But I mean,
it goes back to the fight or also on that aid.
I mean we go through a lot mentally.
It just battles that we go through in our own heads.
And you got to have that confidence,
man.
That confidence is what changes everything.
What was it?
What does it like when you know,
you go from,
I mean I was there,
I was very fortunate to be there for your very first fight in 1997.
Was it west?
All Britain nameless,
all Britain came Alabama.
Yeah.
You came in as a replacement,
right?
Yeah,
I'm actually um,
I watched Jerry bull and her fight and we wrestled in high school.
He went to Livermore high and with tiny Tim and we're at the state meet and I
beat him.
And then I watched him when the lightweight at the time was lightweight under
one 99.
Well,
the lightweight tournament and uh,
I was like,
they can't look familiar.
I remember it.
I was like,
I called tank.
At that time I was training with tank.
Dude,
I want to fight in the UFC.
I can crush these guys to see both lender,
just smitten guys and just have,
they're just pretty much hand in their ass to him.
And uh,
I think it was you could do this.
So yeah,
it's all right.
I will see about getting you fun.
I get a call like two weeks later and says UFC 13.
How much training did you have MMA training before that fight?
Um,
probably about two months.
And what did you do during that time?
I wrestled,
I wrestled and I,
man,
we had a street fight.
I'm,
I grew up in the 80s punk rock era.
We used to slam dance and there was no guns and people don't have guns.
Romance fought.
We fought and I got in fist fights,
got my ass beat a bunch of times.
My brother Marty and Jim and Mike and their brothers or their friends.
Um,
but I just came from a wrestling background.
I knew how to street fight.
I mean,
they're not fighting us.
So that's how you looked at it.
He looked at it and look,
I got,
I got my wrestling,
I'm gonna take this guy down.
Beat his head.
I knew,
I knew at the time,
I mean I was a state champ.
I was very confident and I knew that guys couldn't stop my double.
These guys weren't college wrestlers and I know I would dominate.
What is it like to,
there's this gotta be completely different mindsets from the first time you step
into the octagon to as your career's progressing to becoming a champion.
You know,
this,
uh,
this gotta be a lot of differences in the way you approach things.
It was,
I don't know,
I just really didn't think too much about it.
You know,
I don't want to get lost in the beginning.
Wasn't like all of a sudden,
this is what I'm doing.
All of a sudden,
boom.
I was like,
I'm trying to sound and all of a sudden was like,
wow,
it's more stepping in the cage.
We went,
Holy Shit.
Well what am I doing?
What's going on?
And people listen to me.
I'm going to drink your Tito Ortiz.
No,
no.
I was an average guides me.
It was like,
okay,
don't make a mistake.
Keep your hands up.
Because at the time we buddies in average guy,
that's the secret.
At the end of the day,
everywhere person,
everybody's just a person.
I mean,
I'm just a person.
I just work really,
really hard.
You know Paul Herrera who fought in UFC,
it was a David versus Goliath.
He was my high school wrestling coach and a,
I was training with them at the time and I remember him saying,
and this was the sign of cockiness,
he's like,
Oh,
what is Gary Good was going to do arm wrestling to the ground?
Oof.
And then I was like,
I wouldn't think of it that way.
I would look and see what he really does.
And I started watching,
seeing some of the other cop,
Quito or some of their fight,
and he did.
And that was one of the scariest Kaos ever that was,
I was there and it,
and it shook my heart.
I was like Blam.
He got blasted and I was just like,
Holy Shit.
I remember at the time,
my girlfriend,
Kristen,
she was like,
I don't want you to happen.
What happened to Paul happened to you?
I'm all,
I'm going to train hard and I can,
I can let be too confident.
I'm just gonna go in.
I'm going to know him to fight.
I'm gonna fight as hard as they possibly can.
And I did.
I worked my butt off.
You know,
I'd run four miles a day,
six days a week.
I would wrestled three hours a day with Jujitsu,
two hours a day.
I,
I'll do my boxing.
I didn't do kickboxing the time I just did boxing.
Um,
I didn't spar that much cause I mean,
at the time I didn't,
I didn't really understand what spartan was about.
You know,
we,
we did a lot of wrestling.
We did a lot of crown groundfighting stuff.
We did.
Studies didn't do much.
Stand up,
fight it.
Yeah.
Not really.
I mean,
I tank was the guy who I'd have to spar with and I didn't want to get punched in
the face by hand.
Everybody saw what he did.
The guys,
I never got a chance to spar with him.
Um,
but I'd Russell from all the time,
we'd just submission wrestling all the time.
I was a lot faster.
Um,
but it's just one of those things as it progressed,
when I first started to,
like when I went to cal state Bakersfield,
after I fought my first time,
I took a year off,
I went to cal state Bakersfield to try to finish up to get my,
you know,
my teaching degree and uh,
I get my major in physical education and my minor,
especially in the case in teaching and the me and the coach and CSI.
And I was like,
wow.
Then this is something that I don't want to do.
Um,
I got an opportunity to go back and fight for the UFC.
And I was like,
all right,
I'm going to kill this coach and gold at cal State Bakersfield or I'm going to
leave.
So I packed my stuff up,
dropped my stuff off at his school and said,
you know what?
You're a piece of shit and I'm gonna share.
Anybody respects you.
I'm either gonna kick your ass or I'm out of here.
So I packed my stuff and new hall,
we get back down to Huntington and got a job at Spanky's adult bookstore.
And one of your first sponsors?
Yeah,
one of my first Spanky's Spanky's triple x and my first sponsor,
adult novelty store.
I worked there,
I sold merchandise.
I was probably the highest selling guys are.
I was a great salesman.
There's some interesting stories I would happen there,
but uh,
yeah,
but no beyond that,
uh,
you know,
I started training,
I got my first fight back,
so it was like an opportunity in the middle of a play.
It was,
it was the best door for you?
There was,
it was,
uh,
he,
he actually,
the owner from the company knew that I fought and he goes,
there's a UFC in Brazil.
And I told him I wanted to go.
He said,
how about I pay for your air ticket and your hotel to go out there?
Me and one of my other friends,
we went out there and I made my first little fighter cards and it had my phone
number on it,
had my email address on it.
It had a picture of me with my back to the picture and said,
Tito Ortiz on a number walking up the John Preti and go on.
I want to fight.
I'll kick any of these guys as I kicked that frank share marks.
Guy's ass.
I'll kick his ass.
I go,
I want to fight.
And he looked at her like,
who the hell are you?
I go,
I'm Tito Ortiz.
I go watch UFC 13 I got almost be Guy Metzker in the finals.
I got beat up,
got west,
all Britain at the time I was a young kid.
I was cocky.
And how old were you?
I was a 22 I just know 20 I just turned 20 yeah,
I just turned 22 I was a young kid and I mean at the time I was hungry,
man.
I was,
I had nothing to judge a man.
What the fuck comes out of his mouth?
And He's 22 I believe me.
I,
at that time I didn't care.
I didn't,
I mean I always thought was the toughest guy in the world.
You did not have a good childhood?
No,
I came from nothing.
I mean,
I think God has put me in the right way,
is a lot of things,
you know,
but I'm,
don't get me wrong,
I don't go to church all the time.
You know,
I just believe in being a good person.
you treat people how you're going to be treated.
Uh,
you know,
I never tried to step on the way to get ahead.
That seems to be self evident.
Right?
I mean,
pretty much everybody who has a brain knows,
treat people well and good things happen to you.
There's a,
an ethic to the world,
right?
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
you know,
I mean I had a problem I used,
I used to steal a lot when I was a kid cause I never had anything.
My parents were drug addicts.
You know,
we lived down in motels,
we lived in cars,
live in people's garages and everybody else always had something.
And I never had anything.
My parents could never buy him anything.
So,
and I would still have to put clothes on my back.
I'd still put food in my mouth.
Um,
you know,
so that was always your reality growing up.
Your parents were drug addicts your entire time to up.
It was about six years old to about 13.
Um,
it was,
it was.
So that was just a reality.
That's all you were at.
I go to therapy right now.
It's like I talked to my therapist and psych and I realize the things that I do
and why do them,
it's like,
okay,
this is the reason why I do that.
This is right.
The reason why I do that,
it's a learning process and I think each person has us individuals,
we got to understand ourselves and how we're brought up is usually is how we
become.
But you still have that opportunity to make those decisions.
Yeah,
you have the opportunity to change your behavior,
but you have to look at it and it's hard to do.
It's hard to,
it's hard to look at your say.
It's challenging to look in the mirror and to question yourself,
don't,
I mean people could say,
oh,
that guy's talking shit about me.
No,
maybe that person is speaking the truth about you and you're just too in denial
to really realize it.
And I'm still learning it.
I'm human.
I'm still learning.
And I look at those things as a,
it's a challenge.
It's a challenge from God.
You know,
I could be a quitter.
I could be a complete drug addict right now and be strung out on heroin.
I was,
my parents were,
or it could be in prison right now and doing a life term for killing somebody
for something.
Um,
or I could be dead.
I could have been shot as one of my friends were when I lived,
grew up in Santa Ana.
Um,
but I was able to make a choice of my future and I think through my UFC career,
people had to kind of a bad image of me because of the bad boy image.
But I was just trying to sell.
I was just trying to do what Ali did.
Um,
you know,
I was trying to do what some of the bad guys were that got the most attention.
You know,
at Tyson's heyday he had said some of the most negative things ever and people
loved him and that's why he was selling,
you know,
1.5 million pay per views.
I mean,
I've done that.
I've,
I've done that for the USC.
There is a part of it that is show business and people kind of have to
understand it's like rappers.
Do you think they're really going out shooting people?
Some are from Atlanta and you never know.
Some of them,
some of them get a little caught up in the game.
Yeah.
But you know,
you got to find that happy medium.
You know,
where you realize that it's about yourself to make the decisions.
It's not about others.
Who made you make those decisions?
How did you get out of the,
the,
the place where you were when you were growing up with drug addict parents?
How did you get out of that?
What was your mindset like when you were separating from your parents,
becoming your own person with that sort of a back room?
My mom gave me,
gave
me 800 bucks when I was 18.
I graduated,
she goes time for me to BMN BNN and I wanted to move out too.
But she was like,
here,
time for you to be a man.
I moved on with my brother Marty and his wife and um,
I was doing drugs.
I mean I was doing,
I mean crystal,
we smoked weed,
we drank on the weekends,
but I worked at allied moving service and I would work 16 hour days,
um,
drug down,
uh,
to kind of forgot about Roselyn a little bit.
And it was about a year after high school.
Um,
I was at some club and I was party and one of my coaches,
old coaches pulled up to me.
He's like,
t say,
yeah,
you do not write,
Ma'am much.
I'm fine.
I'm looking at myself.
What do you mean I'm fine because you don't look so good,
man.
No,
I'm cool man.
I'm good.
Cause even thought about coming back in wrestling,
going back to school,
I was like,
yeah,
but I mean I live on my own.
I'm just trying to make ends meet.
And he's like,
you know,
I tell you what,
I'll do.
You come to my cut on my,
uh,
my office and we'll see about getting your financial aid,
financial aid.
And he goes,
you're Mexican.
Ran to go.
Yeah.
He goes,
we get your financial aid or pay for your schooling,
pay for your bucks,
and possibly give you some type of stipend to pay for your house or apartment.
And I go,
really?
So that's,
it was a Saturday night and I was partying was at Rhino Room in Huntington
beach.
I was drinking when party that night.
Sunday rolled around,
I was up still doing drugs,
doing crystal that nine,
I looked in the mirror and I didn't recognize myself.
I was 182 pounds,
183 pounds,
six foot two sucked up.
I mean,
people see me when I'm making weight at two oh five and my size now it's the big
difference.
But Wayne,
185 pounds pimples all over my face.
I look like a drug addict and it scared me.
I looked at myself and I said,
you're turning into your parents here and I have these with myself all the time
just to to read reality check to check myself.
And I woke up that Monday morning,
I called allied,
we've been served and I said I can't come in today.
They're like,
what do you mean you can't come in today?
You mean you can't,
you can't call on it cause they are not coming into that girl.
I got to check it out the school thing or you don't come in today,
you're fired.
I go,
well I guess I quit.
Then walked into that office and the coach had a big smile on his face.
I'm a to Doherty.
I was kind of a big smile on his face and he was like showed up.
I want to give this a try.
That's amazing.
So this is just based on your wrestling ability that he saw from high school.
He said,
this kid's got some talent and let me give you an opportunity to get out of your
situation.
You knew you were in a bad spot.
Yeah.
I mean,
I knew that I was in a bad spot too.
I just wasn't,
it's not one of the best things about competitive athletics that you know,
that you can't get an opportunity like that.
Well,
you know,
I don't think you can only just an athletics.
I think it's in general in life,
there's always some of them give somebody an opportunity and I think people got
to take that advantage and take that as a situation of maybe it's God giving you
a chance.
Maybe it's someone who's looking out for you.
I mean,
I've done it through my whole career.
I've,
I've tried to help guys come up and,
uh,
you know,
I look at it w it was a gift.
It was a gift to me and it was a challenge.
It was a challenge from God.
I had the sand.
You want to become a real person.
How hard is it to tick that crystal?
Um,
that was almost
four months,
three months,
three,
four months to kick it.
Yeah.
I mean,
my situation was when I drank,
I would like to party.
That was it.
I wasn't like I was,
I had to do it to get up and go.
I had no,
I mean I hate the feeling the next day,
the burnout feeling.
I hated that,
that suck.
But what really,
what it was,
I didn't feel normal anymore.
I didn't feel that I was able to cope on a normal feeling.
So he just wanted an escape.
I wanted to escape.
I,
it was from,
it's funny because I talked to my therapist,
it's,
it's wanting to get away from that child of always wanting the attention that my
parents never gave me.
And that was,
it was weird cause I was the only way to push that stuff away.
Right then think about anymore.
It was doing drugs.
It helped me,
helped me deal with it.
I dealt with it.
I dealt with through well.
And uh,
all of a sudden when the drugs weren't around,
then I had something else to deal with it.
School,
school kept my mind off of it.
Wrestling kept my mind off it.
The security that I had from my coaches and front of the time,
my girlfriend Kristen,
who backed me,
I just,
I felt great from it.
You know,
I felt great from wrestling.
I felt grateful winning tournaments.
I felt grateful when an a match.
I felt great when I ran four miles,
when I lifted weights,
when I would drill,
when everybody,
when there was no one else in the room and I'd be drone by myself or I'd try
when other guys with me and I'd be drawing on itself.
The coach should be looking at me going,
all right,
a card training's done.
I'm like,
no,
no.
I still got some work to do.
And I always want to prefer be better.
I always want to do something better.
And I think that's what it was.
Just hard work and dedication and yeah,
I mean,
here's another story that I mean I look back and when I used to drugs,
I mean when I was growing up,
when I was with gangs and stuff,
we used to sniff rubber cement and when you hallucinate and so forth.
Um,
when I was growing up I would hallucinate that I was walking down the red carpet
and the set the age of 12 years old,
1213,
I would hallucinate that I'm on a red carpet and people are taking pictures
going Tito this way,
this way,
pictures,
pictures at that age.
And I mean,
I'm assuming anything that I was going to be who I am today as a,
well who you are today,
it's probably because of that very hunger.
I mean it's the exact opposite of what your life was.
You weren't treated as special at all.
So you want it to be Uber special.
You want it to me.
But it was weird.
I look at it and it was like maybe it was that God,
show me that this is what could happen.
It could be possible.
It'd be possible.
Well,
you know,
it could be,
but I mean,
I think everybody's motivation when,
when you're in a bad situation is to improve.
And it's one of the weird paradoxes of life,
especially as a father because I want to do the best I can for my kids and
provide them with the most love and give them the most experiences.
But everybody I know that's interesting.
Had a fucked up life.
Right?
We've got a weird,
I mean,
look at everybody who's very,
very successful.
They have had a fucked up life.
They don't want to be in that position and they don't want to put their family
in that position.
And I've worked so hard to make sure that doesn't happen for my surroundings
now.
Yeah.
I look at it and yes I have nice cars.
Yes I have nice house and yes,
or burner you financially comfortable.
But my biggest thing is making sure my kids have nothing to worry about where
they don't have to steal this to eat.
And I'm not convinced that you're,
you know,
let you,
your tuition or my situation is bad for children as long as they get enough
attention.
You communicate with them?
I do think that they can see life for what it is,
man.
You got to give him challenges.
You have to give.
You have to give them challenges.
You have to make sure that they're working hard for what they're getting.
If you just give them everything they want and they don't,
they say,
well,
my dad didn't get it from me or my dad's get it from me.
So I know my son Jacob,
who's with him right now,
and actually he has all A's in school right now.
He's in private school,
has all A's.
He reads on a sixth grade level.
Now he's in the second grade.
That's awesome.
And our deal is,
is Jacob,
I'll buy you anything you want,
but you got to get all A's in school and you got to do four things for me.
You gotta respect your mom.
You got to respect your students.
You've got to respect your teacher and you have to respect me.
And it gets done.
Deal.
Dad,
I promise you.
And he's a great kid and he has a good head on his shoulders.
Well,
that's amazing.
You know,
you're,
you're really lucky and I'm very lucky.
Well,
it's not even that.
It's also just the attitude and the fact that he gets to see how hard work pays
off.
You know?
I think that's so important to,
you know,
to see,
uh,
like he seen you struggle.
He's seen you up and down,
you know,
he's seen you win and lose.
It's been a part of the whole thing and seeing the actual pain in the,
the,
the actual,
the effort that's involved in becoming excellent.
Yeah.
Let me tell you,
when I fight Rashad last year,
it was the worst call I've ever had with him ever.
And I was like,
you're up to watch Friday.
He goes,
no,
Dad,
I can't watch the fight.
I go,
what do you mean?
He's all,
it hurts when you want to watch you lose.
And I was like,
oh,
well maybe he started crying.
I was like,
what do you mean?
And he's like,
I can't,
I can't want you to lose like you,
you get hurt.
And it scares me.
I just can't handle it,
can't handle the pressure.
I was like,
okay,
now I'm starting to get them.
I was like,
wow,
this is starting to getting right now.
And then I even had realize,
okay,
I mean I've got a couple more fights left than you ain't got to worry about it.
And when I told him my last fight,
it was uh,
in um,
July and he was like,
thank God.
Now we could spend time together and that's how much time I'm away from when I'm
training.
People understand that,
you know why I buy,
it's not like I get in the cage and I fight.
No,
I put him in three months of work in big bath in big bear three times a year.
That's nine months out of the year.
That's a long time.
You're away from the family.
And by the way,
if anybody wants to buy Tito Ortiz is big powerhouse.
That shit's for sale,
for sale.
I'm trying to sell it.
I'm trying to get rid of it.
He fucking Badass.
I saw some photos of it online,
pulled them up.
Five stars,
you can get it.
I tried to get that motherfucker sold.
I bet there's some fans out there.
They probably don't even know if that's your training camp.
And he used to be Oscar de la Hoya is training to della.
That'll be it for himself.
You know,
it started with one home and then he made another home s right next to it.
It's on an acre,
half the land.
And he made it right next to him and it was five or 4,000 square feet,
4,500 square feet.
It got his own Jacuzzi in this room.
Everything set on the inside.
I mean,
it's kind of,
it's arcade system.
I mean it's,
it's a,
it's a mad house for sure.
It's dope.
It's all wood too.
It's all logs.
It's made with law.
It's,
it's,
it's Pam.
It's about as pimps.
You got an,
and I go there and it's rural,
eh?
Yeah.
It's like Lindsay pimp.
It's almost like better than my home.
My house at home.
I'm like Jesus.
But is that it?
Yeah,
that's it.
Yep.
Come on dude.
Look at that place.
That's fucking bad ass.
But you gotta understand.
When I first got to go to big bear,
one was 2001 I stayed in a two bedroom apartment with eight dudes.
Dude,
this is,
so that's the room.
What happens?
What happens if your kid gets straight A's though and wants to buy this house?
That's what he wants you to buy.
That one you can never know.
I mean,
but now our job is,
you know what I mean as a father is making sure that he gets through school,
you know,
and he says he wants to be a fighter,
but I tell him what's our deal and our deal is to make sure that he gets his
master's degree first,
but he gets his masters degree actually.
And you,
he'll be buying this house for me all just getting in and paid for by them.
Go Google it folks.
So,
um,
what I was trying to get at when I was asking you about the psychology of the,
the difference between when you first were like,
fuck it,
let's give this a shot to when you actually have something to lose now.
Like this conversation that you have with your kid where he doesn't want you to
fight anymore.
You know,
it's like I can't watch,
I don't want to watch her lose.
Like,
you know what,
it came down,
I think the couture fight,
it was,
um,
I defended my little tight at the time five consecutive times.
Um,
and I was up in big bear for three months,
the whole time,
three months.
I never left the mountain and I didn't do any PR.
I just,
I sat up there and I busted my ass and I thought I was prepared.
I may overtrained myself a little bit.
Um,
I was the first problem I had with my back.
Uh,
you know,
I came down and got injections in my back.
Um,
I didn't want to pull out.
I was like,
what?
What is it?
What did it feel like?
Um,
it felt like someone stabbed me,
right.
Um,
above my tailbone.
So what did it feel like?
It was in the spine,
the spine.
It was like,
it felt like a writer and I'm like literally right on the spinal cord.
So what happened was a bulge disc,
the disc I bulged and oppressed in my spinal cord and my legs were completely
numb.
Oh.
And it was the worst and it was a month before the fight for five couture.
He knows the worst pain ever and people don't understand.
And I get all the time people will make.
Tito makes excuses and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
People made it.
If you guys ever had back pain before trying to train on it or run on it,
not only when someone says it's,
it's an excuse really.
It's true.
Yeah.
You know,
you could say it's an excuse,
but if you want to have all the information about a guy's performance,
you really got to know first of all what goes wrong and training how many
different dudes go into the cage fucked up or rather how many,
so many times when you see guys you don't even know,
they might have uh,
something wrong with their shoulder or they might have something wrong with
their hip,
you know,
you never know.
And you know,
two people get upset at you bringing that up.
You've gone through knee surgeries,
back surgery.
I had an ACL replacement.
Um,
I fought,
uh,
six months later after I had back surgery,
two level fusion,
my lower back,
l four,
five s one fused.
I fought a year later on when they fuse it,
is it like they did with Nate Corey where it's like a flexible piece of
something in between a plastic they fuse,
they put screws in it,
they bolt them together and then they get like one disc and it becomes like,
why becomes one,
right?
Oh yeah,
we'll actually four became a long,
actually no tube comes one.
And,
uh,
and that,
does that change your movement to change them?
I could touch my toes.
My hands can touch the bottom of the ground when my feet flat.
I'm not a problem at all.
You know,
it was a hard,
um,
recovery.
Very,
very hard recovery.
Very.
I mean,
that was the worst pain I ever had in my life.
I've had ACL surgery.
Like I said,
I had my neck fused,
a c six c seven fused.
I had meniscus,
50%.
That fuse.
Is it the same way?
I'm having an exact same way.
Same exact thing.
I'm a Dr. William Smith.
I don't want us Vegas who did my surgery,
who's the best surgeon in the world?
Um,
and I'll say that again.
Dr. William Smith is the best surgeon in the world.
Um,
I was able to bounce back and fight and I was about to go to bounce back and,
and train.
I was able not to have back pain anymore.
I mean,
it was so bad where when my escalate and I actually was leaning so much on my
right ass that when I got my back fixed,
my seat was still leaning.
It was dented and I would sit in and I was like,
what the fuck Jesus is that,
that is just weird.
And just little small things mean getting up to go to the bathroom and go sit
down and go to the bathroom was impossible.
And it's the same thing in your lower back cause it was your neck.
This,
they're both useful.
Was it the same kind of pain?
Um,
it was pain.
The one of my butt,
or excuse me,
in my back,
would go down to my butt and go down to my legs.
My legs go numb.
The one that was in my neck would go through my whole body.
It was going down my arms.
And this before I fought Forrest and UFC was the UFC one oh six where I had a
ruptured disc.
The disc was ruptured.
And I still find,
I mean,
it wasn't,
I mean I had no choice.
I gotta pay bills.
Right.
But,
uh,
they went in and they fused it.
They took a desktop completely stuck in two bolts and a plate.
And the spy,
the way Brian,
that video's online.
Yes.
That surgery,
you got to see it because people don't understand.
You got to walk people.
You gotta watch this because you'll see this guy's putting in the screws in my
neck.
He's hammering in his neck like his neck as a chair.
Yeah.
And like putting in these bolts in you here.
It's like he's going on the bolts.
It's like he's hammering a leg in on a wooden chair,
Dunk Tito Ortiz surgery,
surgery,
video,
neck surgery.
And that surgery is,
is gnarly.
But you know,
it was challenges,
man.
God gives me challenges,
you know,
I could,
as everyone calls me or tries to call me a pussy for getting,
for making excuses,
I kept it and Pussy and pulled out of my whole career and I wasn't letting it
happen.
Be able to call you a pussy or silly.
You can't,
you can't address them.
There's silly.
It's a look it,
there's so many.
Is that
the video?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
you don't even want to watch this,
but that's the spacer,
that thing that guys screwing.
That's to open the neck up.
Oh look,
no.
Normally this is,
that's me on the ground.
I had him record it just so people understood what they're going through.
This is so fucking crazy,
man.
Now he's clipping out the disc.
Oh my God,
this is not nuts.
You guys see a fucking wide,
your neck is open you up and you'll see the little two guys in there with a
hammer and pulling shit out of the blood on the two right there.
The second through the pipe
on the disc out.
Oh my God.
And he's like,
you know,
he's just pulling a little disk pieces out.
He's pulling chunks out.
Yep.
Dude.
I mean,
oh,
the work they do now is just amazing.
I mean,
like I said,
this Dr. William Smith and Ms God has given him some blessed hands.
Your head is a car.
You're servicing the car that has a broken trend or a blown transmission.
That mother Fucker was straining as.
He's pulling shit out of there.
I just wait until you see the,
the hammer part.
Once this,
he's happy you have no,
he's hammering in the bolt and oh Jesus.
And then the raddest thing is too is when he bought,
when he screws them in,
like right sitting right now,
he just click on the first little tip of the screws and then he goes with his
whole hand.
He goes it right right here.
And now he's tightening it down.
Oh my goodness.
People online.
You check us out in the audio for this.
I mean it was ridic and hear the squeaking.
Oh,
let's hear the squeaking
and it was like tap,
tap,
tap.
Oh.
Oh Jesus.
Fucking Christ.
And then you barely hear him.
It's like he's changing the tire,
but it's actually changing in the neck.
We'll get a space or this fucking giant hunk of metal.
They're sticking inside year after I got this done and I watched it,
so I was like,
you made me you.
I'm like fucking refueled.
Oh,
three millimeter punch.
Ooh,
I like the term while
you were healing up.
Yeah.
Hello.
I was laying in bed.
It was actually got,
I got it done.
It was my son and my boy's second birthday,
Jesse and journey second birthday and they're having a party downstairs and I
was up in bed laying down.
Ooh,
we're talking about it.
I just like,
man,
I wish I'd be downstairs with my family,
but you know the sacrifice that we do to become fighters couldn't even move
around.
How long were you in bed for?
I was in bed for a week,
a whole week.
I have to ride for surgery.
I got out,
I got up,
had a neck brace on.
I stood up,
I could walk to my car.
I sat down.
My friend Juan drove me back,
uh,
Huntington beach for holy Shit.
You drove like when you were in a car?
I was in the car.
And if feel like your head would be like a weeble,
I'm let alone me.
I was on my fandom level heads a little different.
You're in a fandom.
Yeah,
but the raddest thing is,
I had this during the shoot in the ultimate fighter,
so they shot the ultimate fighter and I was getting kicked out.
I got kicked off because I had to get neck surgery and back then the old
provider was shot six weeks before Danny goes,
you can't be seen in public.
I was like,
what do you mean they can be seen in public?
He goes,
you got to wait until we show that get kicked up for it can be seen in public.
Are you serious?
She goes,
yeah.
Have you been selling with Siena public?
They're gonna know you're gonna have to get neck surgery,
mom.
Okay.
He goes,
I had to stay in the house for an extra month and a half and hide.
Yeah.
Literally hide her.
I would go to my physical therapy.
I had a pull to the back door and I was like,
all right,
no one's looking.
I go because at the time Paparazzi would be looking around and stuff.
So I was like,
that's a lariat would run,
make a run to the door and I'd get in and everybody was all hush hush when I was
there.
And it was like,
it was the worst.
I mean not to be able to go out was,
was was hard cause I had a neck brace on and on.
I couldn't take my neck brace off for seven weeks.
So it was,
how long was it after surgery before you could actually train?
Um,
it was probably about two and a half months,
three months where I was able to do a little bit cardio stuff.
Um,
that's it.
Yeah,
it's like I was able to hit the bag a little bit.
So for two months,
nothing,
no movement or a little physical therapy.
You know,
I uh,
um,
Joe down here down in Costa Mesa called a pro sport.
We did a lot of physical therapy stuff.
Rather I was a lot of movement,
some shoulder workout stuff,
a little arm paddling,
biking,
um,
but all very low key,
very low,
low key,
you know.
And the way my doctor put,
he's a cheater gonna understand all those nerve and these are starting to heal
up again for the first two,
three with four weeks you got to chill,
you got to let those things just hill.
So I mean I was eating painkillers like no thing
and when I was like just handfuls of them,
handfuls of them,
but he says you don't want to feel any pain.
He goes,
when you feel pain and gives irritation to the area.
I was trying to be hilled and it's not going to heal that fast.
So I was like,
all right,
I'm never going to fill up time.
So he's telling you to take as many painters,
he sounds like I do to sell on painkillers,
but I mean he,
you got to put it to acknowledge it's not the factor of sound painkillers.
I mean he's not making money off the painkillers he's making.
I'm totally kidding.
Just listeners don't understand that.
Right?
So it's important actually to take those pills,
take those pills,
doctor say take them,
take them when it's time to get off of them.
Stop taking them.
How hard is that though?
It takes a week.
It's,
it's,
it's hard.
You know,
you go through the little shakes and the sick feeling like you're have the flu.
How ridiculous is it that that Shit is legal?
Yeah.
It's gotta be another way to fucking stop pain then that rubber cement bold.
It's crazy.
Cause you know,
people,
they,
the,
they'll take painkillers and then they tried to get off of them and they're in
pain and they're like,
I got to take painkillers due to the pain.
No,
it's because your body's addicted.
Addicted to them.
I know so many fucking people that have had problems with pain pills.
I know a lot of people and there's a lot of kids in her school to get them from
their parents and they're,
yeah,
they're snorting them.
Yeah.
A lot of kids are smoking them and snorting them.
Cause Norton Adderall.
So Calculus while that,
yeah,
it's bizarre.
We were growing up,
I mean kids while we were smoking weed,
you know what I mean?
There maybe the rich kids had cocaine.
I mean that was,
that was it man.
So many people that we're normal people.
And then they had a back injury or something.
They got on pain pills and they could not fucking get off.
Well that's what started my,
My,
my dad,
he had a hernia,
he had a hernia and he had surgery and I started taking painkillers and uh,
my uncle,
cause the doctor said we can't prescribe painkillers anymore and he was still,
I was still in pain.
So my uncle hooked him up with should try suppose heroin.
Oh Bam.
All of a sudden everything life changed from that point on it.
Cause my dad,
he's still in the business when I was young,
I mean I remember when I was five,
my dad had his own carpentry business and he did well.
I mean we,
we lived,
we lived a great life.
I thought,
I mean at the time,
but I mean when I was six years old,
everything changed.
I mean I remember perfectly,
everything changes so fast.
All of a sudden we're in a house,
him to hear my parents fighting all the time and all of a sudden we're in the
house,
we're living in someone's garage.
And then we in someone's trailer.
And when someone,
we're in a car for a while,
they were in the motels and it was,
it was challenging him.
And I'm,
I'm very thankful for my mom leaving my dad cause I got a second chance in life
I think.
Do you feel like you could have ever been the guy you were if you didn't have
such a shit child?
No.
No Way.
There's no way you would have that drive.
Right?
That's,
I wouldn't have the same drive nowhere you'd be,
but I would like little thingies still be a winner though.
Right.
You know what,
I figured something out.
I would,
I may be a little bit better in school and you know,
I,
if I,
if I got a different opportunity,
I think if I got the San Martine,
I'm giving my son a B in a straight a student.
I think I,
I mean my
parents are very artistic.
My Dad was an artist and my dad was a carpenter and my mother's an artist.
Um,
I think I have great brands.
I mean shit like a worrying right now.
I mean the business work I've done already by all the damage I've done to my
brain when I was younger.
I,
you know,
I'm a great capacity of just learning experience and I think that my kids have
that same opportunity now.
But without the drugs around,
well you certainly got Outta MMA to uh,
without incurring some like speech problems or any of this shit.
And we're starting to see now from guys see some of the guys now.
It just makes me cringe and I'm just like,
God man,
all those times,
all those fights and you think it gadget like God is what you see.
You guys stand up and just punch each other in the face.
And I was like,
okay.
I look at boxers.
Yeah.
I mean,
for perfect example,
um,
I actually,
one of my buddies who I back of the day who used to box a Fernando Vargas,
and I know Fernando,
you changed a lot,
a lot,
a lot.
And I mean,
I love him.
He's my boy.
Great Guy.
Awesome guys.
Stand up dude.
Cool,
cool click.
There's no doubt he paid the price.
He paid a price span.
I mean these guys,
they getting in these weird,
when you know a guy before he pays the price and then you see the results and
then I go,
oh,
this is real.
The Trinidad fight was the one that changed everything.
I met Terry Norris once in vague.
I didn't actually meet him.
I was standing next to him,
I should say,
while he was talking to a fan and he was a,
you know,
someone's asking them,
what's,
what's going on with you?
You're going to fight again.
And he was talking and it was almost like,
it was a joke.
I was like,
is he drunk?
Like what's going on?
And then I realized,
oh Jesus,
this is why you haven't seen him in years.
He's fucking punch drunk.
It's just from taking so many blows.
And so is it exciting to put a great show by it on yes,
but to stand there and slug with guys.
Well talk not just that,
it's also the gym wars,
you know,
there's 100% your trail hand.
He got hit too.
Terry Norris got hit by guys like Mugabi when Gabby was a monster.
When he was Kayo and everybody,
he Kao Terry Norris.
It was ugly.
Or did Terry who did Terry Norris Kale.
That was like a vicious Kale puncher.
I'm pretty sure Mugabi take care of Norris to,
I don't want to say that.
Yeah.
I mean,
he looks to my guys now.
I mean guys at Tyson's five,
I mean,
they're not all there.
you see a lot of his guys go through.
Some things have been football players and other guys that have the concussion.
Oh,
Terry Norris CalEd Mugabi Jesus Christ.
Joe Rogan.
I know Joe.
Come on dude.
It was um,
Julian Jackson.
Who the fuck was,
was it that Mugabi like knocked that where it was really ugly?
I don't remember her.
Look.
Terry Noyes had gotten stopped a bunch of times in his career.
Um,
and you know,
the,
the fights that,
where he got stopped,
it wasn't even that,
just that damage that really did it to him.
I think it was June Jackson knocked out during ours.
There was really the gym wars,
right?
The gym wars are the things that people don't see,
but they accumulate.
And a lot of times it might as well be a fucking,
there's,
I mean I've seen,
I've been in gyms were watching dudes who are high level guys.
We're fighting,
we're fighting fighting mean rampage.
Rampage where channel partners.
Yeah,
we would spar,
we would fight.
We would,
we'd kick each other's asses.
We would fight.
I mean it was just that type of thing where we've got the best of each other and
it was like,
all right,
cool.
Well good job of that.
Good job.
All right,
good job.
Some guys can hear that,
but some guys are not that durable and then you slowly see it slipping away on
them and you know exactly what's causing it.
I mean,
my biggest thing was in my training of trainers or I'll be like,
okay,
we're sparring three times a week.
I was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
We smarter and so much for and be like,
we don't want to spar.
I go,
no,
I just want to get my ass whipped every day.
I go,
let's do taught twice a week.
All right.
We'll do twice a week.
Just,
I mean there's,
I mean,
don't get me wrong,
and there was times,
I mean years and years and years that we do three times a week,
sometimes four times a week.
But I mean,
I don't like to get hit.
She tells me,
Hey guy who likes to get hit,
I'm going to show you a stupid man.
Yeah,
well I think that it's,
it's a weird aspect of MMA.
You know,
the,
the guys who just want to stand there and bang,
they just want to stand and bang.
I'm like,
man,
you don't know what you're saying.
Like you're,
you're saying something crazy like you got a ticket.
Okay.
And there's only so many places you can punch a hole in that ticket and you're
just going to give up all these tickets on purpose.
That's just to put on a show called fans love you.
Awesome.
Great.
But when it's time to cashing that check,
are you sure you can count those numbers out there?
Well,
it's like,
I love the fights between the Toro Gadi and Micky ward.
They were fucking amazing fundraiser.
But if you know anything about brain damage and you know anything about what
causes it,
those are the type of fights and those guys are going to pay for it.
Pull up Brian,
pull up a video.
Julian Jackson,
Kao,
Terry Norris,
Julian Jackson versus Terry Norris.
This is the fight that I was talking about,
which was frightening.
Yeah.
Well Jackson was another murderous puncher.
You're knocking guys out and they're blowing small bubbles.
Yeah.
And your branding and working all the way there.
At all.
That's not wicked going.
Hello.
I love it.
Like Mama,
Dad,
dad.
No,
we're not in that home.
It seems like the guys with the grappling based styles that are trying to
initiate grappling more,
avoid a lot more damaged than the guys who are striking on image.
I mean,
if you can put on a show,
I have done a great job in my career of being the dominant person on top.
Yeah.
Well not only not,
I mean,
look at a guy like Anderson Silva barely gets hit and everybody loves watching
him fight.
You don't,
you don't have to slug it out with people.
It's true.
It's very true.
You know,
and you know,
people like watching submissions to,
it's people like watching a guy figured out how to be a killer.
And in the moment MMA,
you never know.
You never know.
But people can't figure out how to beat Anderson yet.
Not yet has been present and very aggressive.
Maybe John Jones would,
what's the catch weight there?
I don't know.
I don't think you should be one.
I think two five.
I don't think John Jones can get any lower than two oh five for the WWE and be
healthy.
That's a Terry Noyes gang.
Kid.
Watch this shit.
Chilean Jackson was
Julian Jackson is one of the most murderous power punchers of all times.
He stuff like that was kissing.
Yeah.
You realize how there's only watched the boxes of the year dying stuff like this
is what does it,
the fucking hour.
That guy,
right hook.
Ooh,
another right hook.
Poor Terry took a few of those in his career.
He just,
I watched him fight dot Dana Rosenblatt.
It was like one of his last fights.
Dana was a friend of mine from Boston and uh,
Dana beat him by decision,
but I remember watching Terry and I find them like he can't pull the trigger.
His body's just,
he just couldn't pull the trigger things too that I talked to Jason Parillo
about,
cause Jason,
you know,
he's working some great guys.
I'll be,
and he goes,
you tell when a guy loses it because when he hits pads,
when he spars,
it's not there.
You just lose your timing.
You lose everything.
I mean,
if it was,
they say,
Jason tells me,
he says,
first goes your legs,
then your body,
then your mind.
Yeah.
I mean you see it.
I mean all fighters do that.
I mean,
thank God my legs are gone.
Thank God my body's gone because my head is still here.
So now it's time to use my head and said of my body and my damn legs anymore.
Did you ever get to,
I mean,
I remember on my brief time a kickboxing,
there was moments I would lay in bed at nine and a half fucking headaches and
I'd be sitting there with my head is throbbing going,
what the fuck am I doing?
Am I head right now?
Like what is the,
did you ever wonder about like,
what's the like where are you at?
Like what's the tally?
What do you,
Oh,
you know what I mean?
No,
you know,
I,
I always felt like I was smoking weed.
Try Smart.
Just like dizzy,
silly,
silly film.
People say some silly shit after they spar.
Like,
like sometimes the funniest conversations you get in with guys who just got done
sparring and then they go eat every day.
Like hammered.
No,
seriously.
That's what they called punchdrunk.
I,
yeah.
Well sort of,
but that's a different field.
That's like a sort of a post workout posts getting punched in the head,
feeling your adrenaline is rushing,
you got cracked.
Some good shots.
He kind of get that.
I ain't even tasting her mouth or like blood.
Yeah.
The copper that doesn't teach you.
Um,
did you ever like,
say like,
how many times can I fight?
How many did you ever like try to like sit down and look at it and say
realistically how much damage there's,
cause we all know there's,
there's certain guys like even boxers that got out in time and you listened to
them talk and they're fine,
you know,
they have no problems at all.
But that was my thing.
I never wanted to take too much abuse,
you know?
I mean,
I think with Dell's zone,
it's a really hurt me.
Literally.
I mean Vandelay Silva who was one punched when our title five when we fought
that made me felt like the world upside what?
Upside down.
Um,
chuck caught me,
you know,
in their first fight with some good,
a couple of good shots,
two good shots,
a good right hand and good left hook.
And uh,
it just feels like your legs could dropped.
Your legs come out from under you.
If they stop working,
stop working.
It just,
everything goes.
I mean,
I'd never been out of unconscious ever.
My career,
you know,
I think rampage and won't respond.
Maybe see some twinkle bells where everything felt
like has been there.
Like,
Oh,
this is been here before.
Wait a second,
I'm not been here before to move.
Right.
But I mean,
I,
I've never been unconscious where I'm on the ground and wake up feeling whole
or,
well,
well it happened.
Thank God it doesn't,
ah,
that's some scary shit.
That's some scary shit.
You know,
I've been able to get up right after like boom.
like I said,
the first time you and Chuck Fahd,
I poked around on my feet.
I was fine and the judge is trying to keep me down.
I was like,
get the fuck away from me.
Let me stand on my feet,
get away from me.
You know,
I'm a little embarrassed,
but same time,
it's just that most things as fighters and his men,
you do,
you don't want to be in that position.
Yeah.
But then there's still didn't want to accept losing to lose.
No,
it just happened.
Yeah.
I mean people don't understand.
I mean as a fighter,
I mean that hard as a fighter.
When I lose,
it's like a loved one died.
That's how much pain it is.
Just like it sucks everything
fighting the soap,
lonely and people don't understand it unless you're a fighter.
They only,
the loneliest feeling there is no growth is laying in bed before a fight and
going,
you had to go out there and fight.
You got to put on a show.
You gotta make it fun for the fans that watch and everything lies on you.
There's no one that could save you.
There's no one that could boost you.
There's no one that can help you throw punches.
There's no one that can help take a guy down.
It's only you by yourself.
And there could be your family,
wives,
girlfriends,
brothers,
sisters,
dads,
mother's going,
good luck.
Kick some ass.
That's as far as it goes right there it goes.
No further than that.
You're the one that got to get in the gym and train every day.
You're the one that gets to push yourself in spine,
do the extra drilling,
do all these extra things.
And you know,
I never really understood it until I started working with Jason Pro and he
explained it to me.
He goes,
man,
isn't this a lonely sport?
And I was like,
fuck,
I never heard of that way.
But yes it is ma'am
lonely.
But it all comes back into that one gigantic moment of the exact opposite of
When you win,
when you win,
everybody wants to be your best friend.
Everybody wants to be a part of the joy.
And not only that,
the moment that you actually win,
like when you tap Ryan Bader,
let me tell you something,
man,
that was about as happy as I've ever seen you because you had gone through a
drought for a few years and it's like you wanted that w and when you tagged them
and you dropped him and you grabbed a hold of that neck and pulled guard and
fucking crushed it and he tapped,
dude,
you were so happy.
You jumped up
watching discovery channel and you see a lion chasing a gazelle and trying to
eat for the first time it was life [inaudible] I was at lion is finally got it.
Fucking finally got it.
I Limor lock in my hands and I was working with producer server doing at the
time and I remember just hooking it,
the guillotine wrap one leg the other leg over and we're just thinking producer
goes,
keep her elbow down to you whenever you get the guilt and keep bro.
But then I kept my old down and I just squeezed everything together and it
wasn't the fact of pulling his head towards me or my body towards me who just
doing a crunch and is crunching everything together,
Russian at all,
squeezing the shit out of it.
I remember it.
I'm not like going to the reference me off cause I'm not going through something
where he didn't tap or the referee has written me off.
And I remember and three,
three days before that I did the ultimate fighter with Michael Bisbing and all
the guys were on the show.
They're like,
Tito,
man,
please do the grave digger.
Please do the greater good for.
Show us how you do it.
I was like,
no,
wait until this weekend because when I dropped Bader and I'm going to drop him,
I'm going to beat him and we'll do something.
Whatever I do,
but when I get it done,
I'll do the grand Duke of free guys.
Crazy that that was the only the second submission in your career.
It really is crazy
because I always tell people you have a very underrated ground game.
When you pulled that triangle off on Machida.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Like that was a wrinkle that a lot.
Look,
there's a lot of dominant dudes,
top dominant especially that don't have that wrinkle in their game.
They don't have that aspect again.
You lock that thing up fucking sweet.
And if it wasn't Machida,
if it wasn't a real Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt,
you would have had that shit.
You went for a tumble with it for the arm too.
And that was my,
that was my mess up.
Um,
you know,
when we drill,
I draw the triangle there from a triangle I go for and bar.
Cause the guy pulls away and I blew it by doing that.
I probably should have never did that.
I should have stayed at the triangle the whole time and all the time.
But I have to catch guys now and triangles,
I just make sure I hold onto it and don't let go.
And I know now to grab onto my shin.
Don't let anything else go to grab your Shin,
just hold on and wait the guy out.
And so for you to Gable grip around the back of the head,
pulling that you pull the neck,
can't handle it after a certain point in time.
You,
you,
you have to,
you have,
there's a guy from Brazil that I moved out here who teaches on my school at
punishment train and Senator Ricardo a Bruin and we'd go over that stuff.
He was like Tito,
like promise.
Oh,
Cyborg.
You know,
Ricardo Abreu,
he's three now.
Right now he's an 85 pounds and he's an up and coming kid.
He's 26 years old and he's amazing.
Amazing.
Who's that?
So there's a Bruce Cyborg or brew,
you know what I'm talking about?
Presumes you just a guy.
I think he might be,
I think it's the same last year I had no,
um,
yeah,
same last name,
but this kid,
he's an up and comer.
He's three now.
He's amazing.
Um,
try to give them a file in the next strike for strike force card.
But he's still got good former fights until the GFC status.
I think it just needs to build his confidence a little bit,
but it's just one of those things,
like I say,
man,
you get those submissions and you do it over and over again.
You used to just making sure you don't make the same mistakes twice and my whole
life and never done that.
Trying to make the same mistakes more than once.
There's some,
there's so few guys that are big guys and have a strong guard,
you know,
for every four Breeshia over doom is a,
a hundred guys that turtles when they put them on their back and it's just,
and when I went to Abu Dhabi was when I started learning,
you know,
I started realizing,
I mean I was a wrestler.
I mean I don't go into my back.
It took me a good two years to see what comfortable to be okay to go to my back.
I'd be okay with it.
But it was one of those things that when I first started fighting,
I was going to my back.
The guys weren't taking me down.
No Way.
I was defending,
defending.
But then you get a little lazy when started,
you started going,
okay,
I'll pull garden.
I teach my guys now don't pull guard.
And that's the least.
That's the last thing you guys,
what do you do if can't take a guy down
though and the guy's fucking you up kickboxing,
then pull guard.
You better be fucking tough.
You pulled guard guard,
he got smashy on top.
Well,
this guys who you can't do that to like look at that Paul Sass guy.
You'd watch that kid out of Great Britain.
Not yet.
Ooze triangles are nasty.
I think he's got eight or nine wins by triangle and he just catches everybody
just caught Jacob Volkman with a triangle.
But I mean you getting that motherfucker's guard,
you're in quicksand.
If someone fights him,
give me an opportunity and I'll show you a defense for a triangle that everybody
can get out.
I just love watching the Chicago.
Really.
It's,
it's a,
you can get,
I mean,
someone could lock a triangle on you and you're going to get out.
Is that that core sort of role or your role towards where the foot is locked?
I had to do is I put em right hand goes on top of the Shim.
Lefthand comes on top of that and I'd do a tripod,
right.
Uh,
put the knee down and literally his legs open up
realize has no choice to get it.
I want to see you try that on for a over doom.
I buy works really.
I,
it'll work off of recent works off DC.
All right,
I got to see that man.
I get to see.
It's amazing.
It's good.
Good Shit.
It's mad isn't what on them.
That's a good sheriff for you,
Brian.
Styling dangerous.
How much,
when you were a in the middle of a training for fights and then you know,
the fight would be over,
how much time would you spend like working on your skills?
We just make constantly making sure you're always in shape.
Like,
um,
did you have a set thing that you did?
Well,
I would take a month off always.
I'm always taking a month off.
Just loud and Jorma enjoy yourself
myself.
It was because I was,
when I started wrestling in high school,
that was my deal.
I would go through a whole season of wrestling.
Someone would start and right before actually right at right and for summer
first started,
we'd have a freestyle wrestling.
And during freestyle,
you know,
for the first month I would work really hard.
And then as soon as I was over,
I'd have a month and a half to chip for school started.
All right.
I get the party,
I get the drink,
have fun with my friends.
And then as soon as school started again wrestling and started,
so I couldn't drink.
I couldn't,
I had to stick with school and I had to get good grades so I,
I would do that.
So I followed her right into college and I got into college.
He did the same thing.
When I got into fighting,
I did the same thing as soon as the fight was over at a party of my friends and
for the first month and as soon as that month was over,
okay,
there's my date,
I'd have a contract sign for another fight.
And I started trying to,
did you feel more pressure at once it became the champ?
Yes.
That's like the walls were closing in and that's when all the contenders were
running at Ya.
Yeah.
It came down to that,
but I always wanted to learn.
I was always going out to learn.
You know,
I'd go out to John Lewis is a,
I got work with all different guys all the time.
I,
I wanted to learn.
I mean,
that's be one thing I can say to guys who are listening who are fighters is
don't ever stop learning.
Don't ever think just because you're with one school that you can't go with
other guys and learn.
Because when your coach says you can't do that and that coach not right for you,
you know,
cause if you're not learning enough and your gym,
you're only as good as the guys you're with.
You got to go out and you learn from others
guys,
it's hard to learn new shit in and try it on fights.
Yes.
Right.
Because a,
you know,
you're worried about doing something where you're not like your double your
grounded pound,
that Shit's in your head.
It's cement.
It's not going anywhere.
I get a guy against a fence,
I'm taking them down.
Right.
But jumping to arm bar on somebody,
it's like,
fuck,
should I really be doing this?
Am I going to give a one position for another position right now?
No,
I probably shouldn't do that.
But it was just one of those things,
you know?
Um,
I got set in mind
ways,
you know,
um,
I got comfortable,
you know,
I,
the guys I trained with,
I would bring guys around me and I,
you know,
I started teen punishment.
We first started,
it was,
you know,
Rico Rodriguez,
rampage myself,
look,
Dell,
um,
peaky rob Fabiana he,
Hi John Louis.
I mean,
there was so many guys.
There's a name from the past.
Fabiano Yhonnie
all right.
A guy turned out to be a scumbag to,
um,
it was just one of those things,
man,
that you just kind of look at that you just tried to bring the best guys around
you.
And when I didn't have the best guys around me anymore,
I was like,
all right,
well I'll just get the guys that I need that I thought I needed at the time,
you know?
Um,
did you run all your camps?
Did you have a head trainer ever?
Did you always,
I'll always had a head trainer.
Always,
always,
always had a head trainer,
a guy who always told us what we needed to do.
I always did that.
I mean,
there was,
uh,
you know,
a couple of times that I,
I had to do things myself just because of my injuries after the couture fight.
There were so many injuries that came back to back to back to back that were
always guiding around things to make it,
make the right things happen.
Well,
it's also got to be very hard for you to develop any sort of a real relationship
with a head trainer because you,
you really were a part of the whole transitionary phase of mixed martial arts.
Even being recognized as a support.
I mean in 97 when you first did it,
it was,
I was there,
man,
we were in the fucking middle of nowhere and it was a weird half fold gymnasium.
And so to get up professional like real head coach,
like it's almost like you've got to train them.
How many guys were there?
There?
I mean there was two really good guys.
I mean there was,
it was funny cause w back in the day there was a kickbox and trainer,
though I
would use John Spencer,
there's a ground guy that I would use.
Uh,
um,
John Lobur.
Um,
and I would do the wrestling,
you know,
I mean,
I can't recall dress and saw my restaurant him that we just drilled.
We draw all the time.
And then as I got a little bit better,
our,
excuse me was I read a file upon my world title and train would call it on Yama.
Um,
who was a kickboxing trainer and uh,
I'd have Fabiani had,
we'd do a Jujitsu,
um,
Rico Rodriguez Doroty Jitsu rampage and spiral.
It's a lot of times we had great sparring,
great rom wrestling,
some of the guys in the college and so forth.
And then about what,
when I fought,
um,
who was it?
Uh,
Vito Belfort,
um,
being Colin didn't get along.
There were some things back,
back and forth.
Uh,
due to rampage.
I'm rampage was in his ear saying Shit and saying,
Oh,
you could be Tito then.
It was never about that mean
rampage were always good friends.
And,
uh,
it just got to think to personal between me and Collin.
Um,
so salsa lease came about because of a regret trans great trainer.
He was one of the guys who pretty much invent the MMA training game.
He was the first guy to do it and the other guys caught onto is when we did the
ultimate fighter.
That's when people have caught onto it.
When I can't have him come in and and do the ultimate fighter and season three
and what that was.
That was a great time for you to man because people really got to see how much
attention and how much focus you put on coaching kids.
This is such a direct contrast.
My friend Tate was on that season.
All right,
on Tate Fletcher.
Unfortunately it was up 10 shamrock stag and a,
he's like Ken Shamrock,
like barely fucking paid attention to that.
I came from a wrestling background.
I mean if any collegiate wrestlers are out there and you know,
you guys got coaches wrestling's a family,
you know,
it's a family.
It's not just about coming in and training.
It's,
you know,
you're okay with your girlfriend,
you're okay with your friends,
you're okay with your family.
That was my family.
My family was wrestling.
That's what saved me was wrestling,
you know,
wrestling saves lives.
And so you were bringing everybody together.
Everything was always,
always,
always a family deal.
And you know,
and with a salsa least,
like I say,
he doesn't get as much credit as he does as he should.
I think,
uh,
cause he was one of the first guys to kind of start the MMA training game.
I think wine,
all of it.
I mean when I had the ultimate fighter,
you've seen all this stuff.
We did,
he did half the stuff,
you know,
he,
I just had the mentality to have them positive outlooks on things.
I would say to the guys to get them going,
to get them pushing forward to push harder in practice.
And it wasn't like you guys better show are you guys are pussies.
You guys ain't going be a part of this.
And No,
it was like,
what did we need to do to make you guys better?
What do we need to do to make this better?
What can I be on a positive influence to you guys to make you guys love to be
here?
And they did.
You know,
you look at Kindle Grove,
you look at Michael Bisbing Hamill,
I mean these guys that came with from my team,
but they understood it.
You know,
bismuth now and he's a huge star.
He understood it.
I mean,
I was a couple of times I've pulled Bisbee around.
I go be the asshole dude.
People hate you.
You're talking about you're right.
I think he gets it annoys him though.
He's getting paid.
Definitely.
And people got understand that you have people,
you know,
I,
I couldn't hear it enough.
Or Dana has stopped talking to fucking about money and I'm paying for my family.
I'm paying for my kids.
This is a business to me from day one.
This tells you to stop talking about money.
Yeah.
He always says that.
He said,
you need to talk,
talk,
talk about money.
Fans want to hear that.
And in fact your fans saying that,
oh,
she was talking about fucking money again.
What do you guys do for a living?
You know,
you guys get in the cage fighting.
You guys get in the gym,
training,
you guys get away from your family for three months at a time.
If Floyd Mayweather,
it wasn't talking about money,
I would think that something wrong with them.
Like check his temperature.
You might be sick is a smart cat when you're making $120 million on a fight,
something right there.
I mean I,
that's smart business and you look at del La Jolla and then the guy made almost
a billion dollars last year.
Pretty good.
These spiders doing different than us MMA fighters are doing.
Maybe I think we're kind of being there being businessmen and fighters are just
being fighters or excuse me,
those fighters just being fighters.
I'm being a businessman.
I understand.
It says that some people though can't do that with their personality.
Their personality lends itself to competing and that's about it.
They like to be stone faced and stoic fade or like that their work do the
talking for them.
But for folks that don't understand,
like if you want to be,
if you want to get paid attention to look when I go to the expos and uh,
you know,
when you're,
when you're signing,
I know that you're a fucking lines and longer than anybody's man sign up for
eight hours.
Meticulous.
Those lines of ridiculous.
I've watched that man.
And there's a certain amount of,
you know,
entertainment to it.
There's a show biz aspect to it.
People have to appreciate,
I mean,
I'm two different people,
man are,
I think,
you know,
I think maybe it was because when I was a kid,
I always wanted to be that person who had the buddy.
I want to be that kid who,
who was accepted in society.
I think you wanted to feel normal.
I wanted to feel normal and I was,
was always dying for that normalcy and I'd never had it.
And uh,
that's the drive though,
right?
And that was the drive and that's what I looked.
I can now and it was just all the fighters that come up now guys,
please,
if you're listening,
and I can explain this enough to you guys.
This is a business.
No more than that.
You come in and you bust your ass and in 15 years,
if you last that long,
you'll have a business in front of you that you be able to,
I made a clothing company,
I made a nutrition,
light,
punishment,
nutrition.
I was able to build a gym.
I was able to not just that,
but make my name a brand.
I was thankful for Lorenzo Fertitta,
Frank Fertitta,
Dana White,
forgive me.
The opportunities that I've had through my career to expose the way I have of
myself.
But the way that to have that for that to happen was to have a good head on my
shoulders,
to never step on anybody to get ahead.
And I think,
you know,
God overlooks us.
You know,
like I said,
I got to go to church.
I don't believe all worship God,
you're the best person world because of that.
No.
How old will have open hands and help people around you and be respectful.
Don't step on people to get ahead and I really think good things will happen and
my whole career I look at it,
you know,
I could've made a a left or I could have made a right and I went the right way
and I'm thankful because of it.
You know,
cause I had three choices in life,
dead or in prison or I am right now and I'm pretty,
I'm thankful to be where I am right now.
I'm not a religious person,
but I recognize that when a person becomes religious or when a person adopts the
ideals of religion,
of wanting to do the right thing,
like the really simple ideals,
wanting to do the right thing,
treat your brothers if they were yourself to go through life with that idea that
you are aspiring to the wants and desires of a higher power.
That's all knowing.
I'm like,
you're going to do better.
It's like it's really simple.
It's not.
It's not whether or you believe in fairy
tales.
It's the idea that you were aspiring to a higher connection with your brothers
and sisters on this planet and with the universe itself.
And if you can call that God that you can call,
you can call that anything you want,
man.
Anything you want,
it makes,
I have,
I have that battle of time with people who were like,
God,
you don't believe in Jesus.
I was like,
you know,
but some guy who someone talked about and so yeah,
maybe who knows?
You don't know either bitch.
They don't know.
You don't know if you,
if you were born in 1972 you do not know about Jesus.
Prove that shit.
All I gotta say is,
you know,
before I go to bed,
man,
I wore,
I brush my teeth and I look who's around me.
It's myself.
I look in the mirror and I said,
did you do something today to help somebody?
Most of the days,
yes,
some of the days.
Now am I going to do something to model to help somebody?
Yeah,
I'm gonna try.
And every day I do that,
I believe in myself.
I'm saying you're going to be a better person by doing that.
I don't need to add somebody else.
I didn't get to go,
God,
please help me.
Because,
I mean,
don't get me wrong.
There's been times that I had been challenged and it's like,
what?
Why,
why are you doing this to me right now?
You know,
there's been times where I'm just like going and the challenges I've been
through,
my relationships,
you know,
personal stuff,
why,
why is my parents treat me like this?
Why,
why,
and all I kept the questions comes to my mind is I'm challenging you.
What type of man are you?
What type of character do you have that you could prove l sort of this
with every moment of adversity in your life,
it comes an opportunity to grow and learn 100%.
And every time I've had,
I mean,
two years ago,
I went to the worst stuff from I ever had in my life.
And um,
just to kind of correct my character,
it was a factor that I,
it was a challenge.
You know,
it was a true challenge that I look back on.
It was just like,
that's a gift for trying to help somebody and I look and I would realize that I
made myself better.
I made myself mentally stronger because I went through the things I did.
Well,
I dunno what you're referring to that you went through some personal thing.
I mean it's,
it's just a part of life.
It's what goes what I said about,
it's weird that all the interesting people I know all it fuck childhoods.
It's like adversity can really make you a more interesting,
introspective,
more,
more well rounded person.
It really can if you allow it to or if you allow it to just decide that all life
hates me,
hates me.
God's not doing anything for me,
so I'm just going to quit being a fucking pussy.
Step up and be a man.
That is,
it sounds like a meathead thing to say,
but that is reality is reality.
It's reality.
A fucking pussy.
You won't be able to step up and be a man.
Step up and make the right choices.
Make the right choice for yourself.
Don't do it because someone else told you,
don't do it because you're doing it to show someone wrong.
I do it because you look in the mirror and you're by yourself and you say,
are you going to do some better today?
Is this an attitude?
And is this a philosophy that you've sort of developed through trial and error
through your life?
100% you sort of slowly patched it together and piece it together.
100%
and I think it all comes down to my children.
I want to make sure I'm a good
dad.
So you feel like it.
But just having these children,
having these kids that look up to you makes you an even better person.
It makes you aspire to a higher calling.
Yeah,
I think so.
I it really started was when I was,
uh,
I was an assistant coach at a marina high school,
Huntington Beach.
I'm wrestling with the kids and watch them go and coach,
coach,
coach.
And it wasn't a factor of this John who had to work hard.
I would help with their relationships.
They would ask me.
He's like,
it's girls can be problems are done.
So you felt like you could provide a service that you didn't get when you were a
kid?
100% because I went to those same type of trials when I was a kid.
I always wonder why,
why?
And I was always the kid asking the questions,
Why?
I always was challenged by that and I think through my life I've lived through
what people have gone through and had quit and have never made it past.
And I've made a pass because I believed that I was able to do it.
I mean there was times when you don't get me wrong,
I mean I'd ask for people for advice.
I mean I would ask for strength and I'd say,
God,
please help me through this right now.
And like I said,
I'm not,
I don't go to church,
but someone has to be able to,
something a little bit bigger to answer to.
When you were a kid and you were,
when you were a kid and you were an athlete,
when you're coming up,
was there anyone who you looked up to,
anyone who you drew inspiration from that you,
you looked at their work ethic.
Like it was a Dan Gable type character.
I watched whole calling them home at all,
all Kogan and Mama leave.
Good guy,
male combination,
inch pop,
don't drive yet.
I remember,
uh,
Howard Cosell said something to Muhammad Ali and Muhammad.
I was irritated at him and he goes,
you're being very truculent champ.
And he goes,
well,
whatever truck lit means.
If it's
good.
I'm that
said,
I mean this sport,
MMA,
it's so new.
I mean,
there's so much stuff that people haven't touched you though,
mark on.
Why can't I do the things that I'll lead in boxing and MMA?
That's my question.
I was asking myself,
why can't I do what whole?
Because we did and Professor Russ,
as far as showmanship and showmanship,
champions style.
I mean,
I won world titles.
I defend the world titles.
I made the star,
excuse me,
I'll retract that.
I helped make this sport what it is today.
I pushed it to the next level.
Yeah.
Maybe I said some shit I shouldn't have said.
Um,
what,
do you have any regrets if you look back,
having grants,
um,
one and I just think it's just some that I,
that I learned and I think it was the only way I knew at the time was the shit
that I said towards Dana.
I'm a,
I'm a human man.
I make mistakes and I was just defending for my family.
That's it.
Bad it's business.
So nothing personal towards,
it was nothing personal and it was never a towards the Fertitta family.
I love them.
I very thankful for everything they've been giving,
given to me and gave to me what I have wasn't for them.
I wouldn't have anything I have right now.
And Dana was my manager,
um,
and he taught me to fight for things.
I remember when I fought for pay per view,
I fought for
those things because he told me to fight for those things.
He's like,
boss,
who's doing it?
Why can't you do it?
We're going to get this from,
from Bob Myerwitz.
We're going to do this.
If these not going to do it,
we'll walk away.
We'll go to pride.
I looked at him like,
I don't want to go fight Japan.
I want to stay here in the states.
It was like,
don't worry about it.
Don't answer.
So we sat for a week and a half.
Is it weird?
Watson,
Dana go from being a manager to a promoter,
the different person.
Complete opposite role.
Definitely man.
Total different.
He's not,
he's not the same person.
He,
he's,
that's not Dana.
All right.
I love him.
I miss his friendship and I mean me and him were boys and I see him change and
he's,
I just,
he's became these became famous.
It's crazy,
crazy,
crazy.
I can't say nothing bad about because he's given so much to me.
I,
I've said everything that I wanted to through my career and it was nothing ever
towards personal towards him.
It was always business and it was no more than that.
I was defending for my family.
I was definitive for as a business [inaudible] brand punishment brand was a
business to me and I wasn't getting locked or I wasn't get walked over on.
Well I get man,
I don't know the specifics of your ear,
your dispute,
but I've known Dana from the beginning when they first bought the organization.
He's definitely different,
you know,
he's more confident now and he's more successful now,
but me and him is,
he live a very different relationship.
They call that cockiness you said confidence,
I guess.
You know,
it's also the Hubris is how he gets things done and that's why he's so good at
what he does.
And he does an awesome job with UFC.
I mean it wasn't for him.
We wouldn't be where we are today,
that's for sure.
He's got a whole lot.
It doesn't give a fuck.
I appreciate that.
I appreciate,
uh,
I appreciate how much the guy works for it and I also appreciate,
I like watching people grow.
I like watching the guy who was not,
and you can call it cocky,
but
my relationship with the dudes very different than yours.
I'm never really had a dispute with him.
Me and him are,
we always get a little narrower.
We talk,
but I can still see I can.
I think you have to have an unflappable belief in yourself to run a company like
that and garlic.
You could say that's negative all you want,
but I think it doesn't do what he does.
You gotta be like that.
I think he's the perfect guy for the job.
It's a business.
Yeah.
I think along with you,
he's one of the more integrity reasons why this sport has become what it's
become.
It's a,
you can't have someone who's nuts running the fucking thing,
you know?
It's a crazy sport,
man.
This ain't a normal sport.
You know,
it's nuts.
I think it should be about the fighters a little more,
but that's just my opinion.
Well,
it is an opportunity and it's an opportunity that you have capitalized on better
than most,
and that that opportunity to,
to really,
like you said,
make a brand,
make a name for yourself.
I can't explain this to a fight more enough is do something different that the
other fighters are doing it as a,
when I first started it,
I was the first kind of make fighter cards.
All of a sudden rampage started doing it.
I mean,
I helped him,
he's dead.
But when you say fight or cards,
his cards with the little,
I make 10,000 of those.
I'm at my 16th edition of doing them.
Um,
I just didn't,
I have one word,
but in my last one,
my retirement or my last one,
but I made 10,000 of each one and wherever I would go,
I'd pass them out.
I would literally sit there and put them on every single chair in the front row.
That's fine.
And I,
it was brand new and I was,
I understood by doing that.
I mean there was a part,
I think it was five years ago where I got a letter from USC saying,
you can't do that anymore.
I was like,
what do you mean I can't do anymore because he can't do that anymore.
It's free.
I was like,
but you can't do that anymore.
You can't promote yourself.
And I was like,
okay,
I'll keep my mouth shut.
Then that was just,
you couldn't put cards on chairs.
What's up with that?
Because people don't want to sweep up a lot of people throwing those cards away.
I mean there's popcorn on the floor.
Come on.
Why do they need to put white paper on the ground?
Brian?
People are supposed to put them in their pocket.
Listen,
that's what happens on a business becomes big.
They also had to start developing corporate rules.
Yeah,
but I say,
I mean as fighters,
if like say I want to be a inspiration of fighters,
man,
you guys got to promote yourself.
I mean USC would do their part.
Yes.
Um,
do you think that's a big part of your legacy?
Like that's one,
one definite thing that you added to the game.
Yeah.
Promotion.
It was about,
I was whole Colton dude.
Yeah.
I followed his footsteps.
Well you were the only guy who was doing it.
Really.
There was no one who is doing it.
Like we were doing it.
Dan Henderson started making fighter cards.
Randy couture started making,
I was making them for them.
How are we getting them done for them?
That's fine.
They understand it,
but it was about Ladell had a fighter.
I have five cards with me and check the down.
I'm chuck the dose fighter cards and there's fans that came up to me and showed
him and he see a little tea punishment logo on it.
And it was funny.
That was funny cause I was back with me.
Chucklito were never friends.
It's going to be a strange thing for you to have watched,
uh,
going from where you did that first fight in 1997 to like,
you know,
seeing him,
Roger worked on the cover of sports illustrated and seeing all this.
It's cool dude.
It's cool.
It does it like to watch this all like,
I mean you literally got on the train at the first stop this,
this last month has been really heart wrenching for me.
It's just one of those things just going,
wow,
I helped get this word is today and it's over,
but I'm okay with it.
I'm cool with it.
I'm good.
I'm good with it.
I'm like,
you're happy with it really,
really happened.
Then there's your people come up to me and like,
so when you're coming back,
when you find I'm like,
I'm done.
And it was like,
it was playing.
I was sending my therapist and he was like,
so fighters,
I mean,
we just kind of bad couple months ago,
but he's like,
so fighters,
we,
I had no boxers.
After they fight,
they want to come back and do it.
I go,
no,
dude,
I'm done.
I made my money.
My kids are there,
their futures is done.
They go to college and go to any university.
They wanted to get their masters.
I'm,
I'm done.
I don't want,
I wanted to do,
I have my clothing company,
he's doing awesome like nutrition.
My punishment tuition is doing awesome.
You know?
Um,
my Jim started to grow,
um,
you know,
I'm gonna Start Doing,
trying to do some acting.
Um,
uh,
I think he used my brain for a lot more than just fighting and I'm sick of all
the pressure.
I'm sick of beard,
expected so much of I be due the 15th.
When you say the pressure,
you mean the psychological pressure of performing?
Yes.
Getting in there and throw a no one.
You're going to get hurt.
No one.
You're going to be fun.
I know you're gonna get her knowing that you got to not letting my fans down,
not letting my family down,
not letting my kids down,
not letting so many people are around me down.
You know?
And people always thinking about,
well,
you shouldn't think about losing.
I don't think about it.
It's not the fact of losing.
That goes through my mind.
Of course,
that just that just maybe 5% of a thought.
Nah,
it's think about,
well,
what if I,
what if I get bounced on my head again and I'm paralyzed?
I had that happen once before I fought forest,
UFC one oh six I got bounced off my head by Aaron Ross.
Son In my arms and legs were completely numb for two minutes.
I was laying in the middle of the cage up in big bear for two minutes.
Paralyzed.
That's some scary shit.
I mean people,
people don't understand that.
People don't see that.
People don't understand what my train of partners wanted to see that my trainers
to see that shit.
The fans don't see that they think or how did you deal with that?
Um,
well like two minutes later I got up the emergency or the paramedics came.
I got up and said we're taking your emergency.
I'm going,
no,
no.
I'm cool.
I'm good.
I'm good tests.
My arms are good.
A Mama cat,
my cat went laid bed,
laid in bed for a couple of days,
uh,
woke up that next day and I just had pains going.
I'm arms.
So I went and got injections.
I got a cortisone injection was my neck.
They give me 15 shots.
So this is the same neck injury that you wound up getting surgery?
I got surgery.
This was started,
this was three weeks before.
You'll see what else?
Six.
This was when I found out that Brock Lesnar pulled out and I became the main
event.
So I was pulling out.
I was,
I had to pay for my pay for my family of course.
But at the same time,
I didn't want any data down because if I would've pulled down and he goes,
well,
here's,
Tito would get fucking plot our batches and good blast me on fucking the
Internet and blasting media saying ddos being a pussy again.
And that's all I thought that's ever came about.
My fans have that questions because of him blasting me and it sucks,
man.
I just wish it never came about that part.
Uh,
but I look at it,
I had to get a surgery,
you know,
I,
I thought it would go away after I got my objections.
It felt better.
You know,
I'm in the third round or that fight when I fought for the second time,
I remember third round and going,
fuck,
I ain't got nothing left.
Don't get knocked down.
Don't get taken down.
You got to match one.
They'd have given him the match.
And uh,
I remember after it was going to God,
I think,
God,
this is over.
I had a fracture,
right?
Eyebrow bone was cracked.
Um,
I was pretty beat up after that fight.
And,
uh,
I remember three weeks before for a month and a half before that fight even
happen.
Dan asked what I do,
y'all can fight her.
I said,
of course I'll do it.
No problem at all.
And this situation came about,
it was already signed from you to do it and thought if I took a month
off,
I came back and shot it in January that I'd be okay.
I can get through the camp and then I would fight.
Chuck was sparring with the guys I was training with for the ultimate fighter
and I got hit with a couple of shots before between trader that would hold,
watch TV laid down,
went to go get up and I couldn't stand up.
I was like,
what the fuck?
I certain feel safe,
same pain or sickness of my stomach.
I was dry heaving with the doctors.
Just said you got to rupture disc and C six c seven.
And I told David,
I called,
told them and uh,
you like okay shirt cause I couldn't mean okay,
sure.
Well do they got a ruptured disc in my neck was like,
all right,
well we'll go.
We had to use doctors to make sure I go,
all right,
so,
okay,
question me.
They showed ruptured disk.
They went in and did surgery five days before the ultimate fighter.
Season 11 was over.
He goes,
we got to let you go.
Like,
what do you mean we got let me go.
You know you're not going to be fighting,
so we need to promote the next fight.
I go,
so you're going to fucking fire me on television.
It was,
yeah,
that's the way it's supposed to be.
Cause I would do that with anyone.
You're like,
dude,
that's fucking,
are you serious right now?
And goes,
yeah.
The show though is to promote a fight.
Right.
That was the idea of,
okay Anthony,
here's a question for you.
Maybe they should work with you.
We would you be of happier.
When rich came in,
you trained along with them 100% instead of making a limelight of sitting chuck
down and fucking saying that telus plenty of fight and chuck getting them.
Oh,
I told you he had pulled out.
He's a fucking pussy.
He pull out,
come on dude,
be real man.
Are you fucking serious?
And that really pissed me off.
That was just over the board about doing that.
Just just to destroy my image.
And that's what they,
they've always tried to do.
And then I took it and you know,
I'm getting real do I don't give a fuck what people say when then when they came
about,
and Dan says that I came out and I was one of the US,
one of the only use fibershed destroy the company.
Bullshit.
I've never been there.
I've always tried to promote and help this company prevail and get better.
And he's only the top guy that's ever tried to destroy me.
And thank God on my fans.
I think God,
I could fucking fight.
Well,
I'm,
thank God I've always spoken my mind.
The fans have supported me that I was able to become who I am.
And the only reason that happened was because I worked hard to get where I am.
And I look at the situation that I had met portrayed and over the last eight
years,
it's been bad,
but I've been able to survive.
And you look at other fighters like Matt Lindland,
he was was a champ.
People forget about them because he tried to stand up.
There's other fighters to tried to do the same thing,
to stand up there,
forgot about,
well,
in,
in the defense of the UFC,
Matt Lindland wore a shirt that was forbidden.
It was a casino shirt and we're a to a casino.
Right?
Isn't that what happened at a way in,
so that's why they banned them.
Um,
I,
I don't know.
I don't want to speak to the specifics of his detail.
Yulia,
same situation as recur Rodrigues and he had fucking pallet or a station on his
back,
right?
Yeah.
Rico stayed around.
But just to kind of go back on where the conversation about the ultimate fighter
now with Dominick Cruz and,
um,
you're right.
A favor.
[inaudible] why didn't Dominick Cruz go home?
We heard himself on the show.
Okay.
Why didn't he go?
Well,
I,
I think,
uh,
it was late in this,
in this season is it wasn't it?
Yeah,
but mine was five days left.
I don't know man.
I know,
I know that you,
I'm just looking at,
Oh yeah,
no,
I'm just looking at some issues,
but I'm just looking at the real,
real questions that,
you know,
things that we think it's unfair to bring this up unless he was here as well
too.
You know,
cause I don't know all the details of it.
I'm sorry that that had happened with you.
Yeah.
It's your set.
Just things that I always think about that just a,
I think my fans are really bummed about it.
They have those same questions.
So you feel like you just unfairly fairly portrayed as far as like your injuries
and they try to make fun of your character or
100%.
And it was to,
to downplay me and,
and you know,
like I say,
man,
that that's behind me now.
Um,
but let's,
so,
so still things that I,
I still hear all the time for my fans and I still hear from my family and it
hurts my feelings and when my kids start talking about it and they get bed in
front of school for things like that,
that's my kids man.
And it's,
that's challenging I think what the kids say to year kid like,
oh my kid just saying,
oh,
your dad's a pussy.
He,
yeah,
like gnarly stuff didn't he gets tense.
Hilarious.
It's hilarious that kids would actually have the balls to say that a former
light heavyweight champion of the UFC is somehow a pussy and low bar,
but the rash thing is the only association they get that far.
I was from Dana because my dad,
mom,
I,
my kids,
all you,
he's a champion.
What are you talking about?
How can you stand that he's all just,
that's what Dana White's is and it's like a 10 year old kids,
man.
They're just always trying to take their names down and go to this school and
just give him a wink.
The raddest thing is it actually,
it's a private school and I went and talked for career day,
my school,
and then I kind of told her my story about me coming up and everything and how
my name,
my real name is Jacob.
Of course I'll listeners,
you don't know my true name,
not my true names,
Tito,
but my real name's Jacob,
my birth name.
True.
And a real name.
I only have a real name.
I have a face with him.
What's your,
what's your fake name?
What's your stage?
Burbank.
Bad boy.
Brian Redman.
Yeah,
that's a quadruple be right there.
But I watered the lawn after Seth before seven.
He'll give a fuck.
I don't give a fuck.
All kinds of town ordinances and shit,
but like my,
my real name's Jacob in the Bible.
Jacob rustled against an angel and Jacob lost to the angel and the angel save
his life.
Well,
Russell and saved his life.
Wrestling,
saved my life.
My son name is Jacob.
He loves wrestling now.
He just took second in the state just this year at 10 years old.
That's pretty awesome.
I know.
It's really awesome.
I don't know.
It has to do with some other dude named Jacob who was born a billion years ago.
Yeah or not.
He wrestled against an angel.
Did he really do?
Yes.
In the Bible read.
Yeah.
I don't think it happened.
You really thinking he wrestled the angel.
Of course he does.
Probably sleeping bag.
I had a crazy fucking dream and he told him he ate some mushrooms.
I'm like smoking some weed,
right dude,
I was,
I was wrestling on a dude with wings.
It was really fucked up because I just,
I just remembered that story and then it just,
I,
I associate it and be,
like I said,
I'm not a Bible thumper person,
but that story just hit me,
hit me riding home because wrestling saved my life and I made a shirt.
Actually people go to punishment.com and it says wrestling saved lives and the
rest of you have seen that shirt.
Oh,
I've seen a lot of people wearing it a little bit lately.
It's one of the cool things about punch mathletics he sponsored many fighters.
Yeah.
I to fire a lot of fighters wearing your shirts.
I tried to give him,
I give him an opportunity to know that they can make a piece of the shirts that
we'd make personally for them.
We give them a big chunk so they could help promote and that's what it comes
down to.
I wanted to show guys as business wise to promote.
When you got to do to do it.
People say,
well I'm just gonna wear a shirt and I'm going to sell a bunch.
No,
you gotta get on Twitter,
you got to follow,
you've got to post pictures about it.
You've got to make the interest for the social media,
for people to understand you of who you truly are.
And I think that's what it really comes down to that I'm helped.
Now you,
you talked about counseling that you've gone through counseling.
Did you do any while you're fighting?
Did you do any sports psychology work?
Nothing.
No.
I tried it and when my,
when I got married,
I'm with my aunt star Kristen.
We're going through a relationship counseling and I started to get soft I think,
cause I started realizing why I was reacting the way I was starting to get soft.
I thought,
I think it was just myself.
I started getting to my feeling,
touch,
you know,
my,
my thought it was going to fuck you up as a fighter.
Yeah.
I thought it was,
I stopped
Claris you know,
I took yoga when I was young.
I stopped taking it because I thought if you were enlightened it would be bad
for you as a kid.
Median it wouldn't be,
you wouldn't be as fun because a lot of my fucking comedy,
it was like being mean about people.
Comedy is fucking funny.
I,
I've never laughed so fucking hard in my life.
That shit is funny.
Oh,
thank you.
You're funny.
For me,
I know that that thing like,
you know,
for me,
uh,
my child who was not nearly as hard as is
yours a,
but I had a bad dad.
My parents divorced when I was five.
My mom remarried.
My Stepdad,
who was a great guy.
So from seven on my childhood is pretty,
pretty.
God damn good.
You know,
everybody's Nice,
nobody beat me up.
But my father was a terrible person and I have these crazy memories of my dad
beating up my mom.
And I didn't realize until I was a grown man that that was why I was angry all
the time.
I really didn't realize that,
you know,
a person looks at their father,
a child,
especially a boy,
you look to this is,
this is the person has already done it.
This is my goal.
You know,
I want to be like him.
This is my superhero.
When you see a,
a terrible person place of that and you just feel like the,
the world fucked you with a shitty deck of cards,
you want to repair
the rolled back by being in that same fucking person somehow or another.
I'm very thankful.
My Dad was actually good till I was about six because I remembered the loving
feeling of my father.
But then the abstinence after I was six of my mother had my father.
Um,
and I,
I'm like talk to him and talking to my therapist and that's why I've always
looking for a mother figure around me.
I know Mike girlfriend,
Kristen,
I mean the,
I,
I started dating her after my second year out of,
or my first year at high school and uh,
I was waiting the whole time,
you know what I mean?
It was just me and her and I was always looking for that motherfucker,
And gender together,
she's perfect for me.
I mean we are,
have the same associations in life coming up business wise are,
you know,
we're never supposed to be successful.
We didn't have loving parents and thought it ah,
but we still are missing that same type of role models in our life,
you know,
and her,
her mother died at the age of three.
Her father was never around.
Um,
so I think we just kind of work hard to be the best parents that week possibly
can be.
And I think work on each other and making that happen.
It is what it comes down to.
I think,
you know,
being
learning from it.
Well,
you know,
also learning from,
how about you talking about it,
man.
You know,
this shit wasn't available when your parents were coming up,
nor when my parents were coming in.
We didn't have anybody sitting around talking really about relationships are
real about being raised by cons.
Dude,
seriously.
I mean,
and I mean in any people who are parents now who I fucked up,
parents make a difference.
Don't keep that cycle going.
Fuck the cycle.
Fuck the cycle doesn't have to keep,
you can grow and learn.
Grown learning,
green,
move on.
Find someone else who has a great family and try to be something like that.
Well,
this,
this conversation alone,
I'm sure,
look,
this podcast gets heard by a lot of people over the world.
I guarantee you it's going to speak to a lot of people.
So you know,
and like I said,
I can't rehearse this over and over and over and over again is be truthful to
yourself and don't step on people to get ahead.
And I'm telling you good things happen for that.
Good things happen and you got to embrace the losses.
You gotta embrace the losses that life hands you because you're not perfect.
No one is,
you're not born perfect.
You got to embrace the losses as far as the relationships he got to Britain.
Embrace him in your social life as well as embrace him in your,
your business life.
You got to learn and the only way to learn is to try and fail.
That's the only way and one way to do it,
man.
Just keep getting up,
keep moving forward,
learn,
grow,
continue to analyze yourself.
Right?
Yeah,
I know.
I mean,
it's a learning process.
like I say every,
every day,
you know,
test yourself.
What's beautiful in this day and age,
what's beautiful in this era of endless information is that kids of listening
right now,
people who you can influence and I guarantee you they're going to get something
out of this.
I guarantee you when parents,
I get indirectly even old people,
man,
no one's no one's too old to old to and Brighton.
When I did a the apprentice,
I had a whole different demographic.
When I did that show,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
I walked in the airport and you're just like 80 year old old ladies,
Kyla Zoopla.
Hi Tito Howard
was such a nice guy.
I started watching the ultimate fighter and person y.
That's my fight game.
He was like,
but you're still rhythm mass guy.
Thank you.
Very [inaudible] on the celebrity apprentice with a Lennox Lewis.
Who wanted that y'all uh,
Pierce Morgan wanted that year.
Lennox Lewis.
What was he like?
He's a cool cat.
He's,
he's,
he had another fight.
He's a bad motherfucker.
He laid back cool,
nice guy.
And when not part of the couple of times.
He's a cool dude.
Really,
really,
really cool guy that's playing bad motherfucker.
He's calm,
he's calm,
collective.
He's just like,
cool.
He just a cool black fuck.
Just like,
and he's just,
he's cool man.
He's really loved about Lennox Lewis Madison.
He had some fucking bad losses,
like hosteen rock on knocked him out like he got cut and here's that Kodak and
come back and yeah,
I mean he was a real human dude.
He wasn't,
uh,
like when Tyson was the king,
it was like,
it was Tyson to the destroyer and then it all fell apart.
But with Lennox Lewis is like,
you know,
like he stumbled and he got back up by humble.
Bladimir Klitschko is another one.
You got stopped a bunch of times.
Corey Sanders knocked him out,
you know,
it looked like it looked like he was losing it.
It looked like Vladimir was never going to be the dominant guy than he is today.
Yeah,
I love a even an over him store.
I love a guy moves forward.
This Tito and the celebrity apprentice,
is that like,
it was a lot of work,
man.
That was me walking out and let me tell you,
after eight straight weeks,
I was like,
thank God I'm going home right now because I had an opportunity to have an
opportunity to sell out and step over Amarosa call around and just make it look
like shit.
And I didn't.
I was straight up,
dude.
You know,
and I think um,
Trump's seen that Trump goes,
he knew what to you though.
You're an awesome guy.
You got some great things ahead of you.
Um,
cause she didn't call Amarosa if you,
you're really,
if you were going to serve the public,
you should call her.
I was like chucked her out.
We had around fear factor.
That bitch is crazy.
Yeah,
she was.
She's a cool Stephen Baldwin,
Steven Blah Blah.
She's actually a cool lady.
Dude.
She was actually,
it was a cool lady.
But when the cameras came on,
she was,
she's hustling.
Yeah,
just hustling.
Steve Baldwin tried to sell you on Jesus for about a half a second,
but not really.
No.
He's a cool dude.
And then he realized that I was with Jenna and he was like,
okay,
who's that?
Pretty girl.
The blonde.
Oh,
that's his daughter.
That's his daughter.
Yeah.
I dropped my daughter and she's a really cool girl.
Really,
really nice girls since it seems her,
it really cool.
That'd be a great Trump's daughter.
And who are all the other people that,
who is that?
She's a model supermodel.
Um,
that was some guy from,
Oh,
here's,
here's Borg was really show.
He wanted that.
He really
is he cool guy?
Yeah.
He's a pretty cool cat.
He's smart.
He's a very,
very crafted,
you did for sure.
Yeah.
He's like the Anti Larry King.
It's like completely like he really is paying attention.
Yeah,
no,
he's a smart guy,
dude.
I'm sorry.
He's crafty.
He comes from,
he has some great ideas is we're uh,
uh,
when he was a,
was a project manager or whatever,
but uh,
he was a good,
but really good dude.
He has some good connections.
He has some really great donations.
But to me on that show was put a light on the MMA of course.
But for charity,
what am I trying to,
Saint Jude's Children's hospital.
Um,
I raised over,
I think it was $90,000,
just from the show.
Um,
but then,
um,
$100,000 were donated to,
was it saint Jude children's Hospital under my name.
So I mean raising that much money for Saint Jude's,
I was going to biggest thing to help kids,
man.
I want him.
That's awesome man.
That's awesome.
I think this podcast is going to help a lot of people,
man.
I think,
I think people understand,
you know,
where I come from,
and I know,
I think people would get so associated automatically with the ultimate ultimate
fighting.
Um,
well it's point to,
it's so easy to point,
fuck,
this guy sucks and it's got,
it's got to,
so it's so easy for people to do that.
People don't understand it until they get in the cage and they fight when they
get in the gym and lift weights.
Like,
Oh,
I'm sore right now.
I fucking,
I ran three miles a day.
I'm sorry.
You don't know what,
sorry as well.
Not only you,
you came along in the time where the,
the ultimate fighter didn't exist or you know,
ultimate fighting and MMA was,
it was in,
its like really its infancy when you came along but you also came along in an
age where the Internet was at its infancy.
It was the first time we're athletes could get shit on every day by a million
youtube people and Twitter people.
Nothing that I think too,
I said it
fighters were in the is don't listen to the fans,
don't listen to them.
Be telling you man cause it,
it can,
it got to me,
I got to a point where I was like,
you know what and I have,
I've I block people
like no other,
no the negative stuff.
I,
since the bait are fine,
I have no more negative stuff.
I don't battle back and forth.
People,
I don't call people
loud,
I don't say shit.
I just don't wear the,
I just block them or reading them.
Listen,
just block them.
Fuck the negative all about positive baby.
That's what I'm talking about.
And I live in my life since like that in life has been so much better because
when you involve yourself into a positive environment,
it just spawns more positive.
While his positivity and it,
it sounds kind of Hippie,
but it's true.
It's true.
It is.
If you involve herself enough negative energy,
negative is going to come about you and everything around you can see it goes,
God man,
this stuff won't stop.
Leave me alone.
It's like Nolan on it.
Yeah.
You know,
I was it right before the Bader fight.
It was funny cause everyone,
Dane,
every one,
and we're just talking and just you're
done.
And Dot.
A.
Dot.
And I just,
you know what I'm believing in myself.
I remember just thinking myself,
I'm going to leave myself.
No more fans talked.
I can't listen to that.
I just,
I just say,
you know what?
I'll watch to those Bader fight.
I remember doing an interview,
him going,
the guy's so what are you gonna do after this fight?
Since your career is going to be done.
And I looked down at my goal.
When I win,
you'll see like a wet,
I go watch when I,
when you'll see it was actually showdown Joe from Canada.
I go and when I win you'll see and no one understood it.
I go,
just watch.
Watch what I win.
How annoying is it talking to reporters that are telling you they're going to
lose that ignorance?
Ignorance is bliss.
It's so stupid.
First of all,
like people always say,
you know what's going to happen this fight.
I always say,
uh,
I don't know.
That's why they got to fight.
The only reason to watch it because you don't know.
You don't know.
You don't know what the fuck is going to happen.
That's my thing.
I'm on UFC and I think that's why Dana and Joseph to do such a great job.
It's not like boxing fight.
It are built.
You wouldn't see a UFC guy built.
No Way.
Boxers are built to be 28 now.
When you say built for the uninitiated,
what you were saying is the set up with easy fights set up with these other
slowly tested to slowly tested and there were 28 now and they're built to become
world champions and they're building them at least to have a good financial run
at the title.
Yes.
Highly respected rank contender.
Exactly.
And it's smart.
That's smart business.
If there's two situations you can have a WWE or are you going to have a
professional wrestling?
Right,
right.
Excuse me.
A professional boxer as in WWE,
they're washed and guys in and out so fast that you don't really get a chance
to,
well,
it's real though.
It's not fighting,
but still it's making money.
Okay,
I see what you're saying.
So they're having guys that are getting put in every single week while different
guys.
You're not building one single person now as inboxing.
How you have guys like del La Jolla guys have like golly.
And they were built it coming up.
You know,
Delaware,
he me as he fights his first six seven eight five ten five 15 fights and all of
a sudden when he's 20 and then now he starts fighting guys who at the tail end
of their career now he's knocking guys out a holy shit.
We also,
I think you have to take into account that boxing has been around for so long.
They really have their situation down as far as like how to develop a fighter
correctly.
If you wanted to look at it from the point of view of the fighter,
that's the way to do it.
I mean the way to do it is to be tested slowly where you know or you know
there's this fucking John Jones type dudes.
It just jump into the deep end of the pool and dominators exceptions for guys
like that.
Guys like John Jones is just a tremendous athlete.
That guy respect for that guy like no other,
he's amazing.
I watch the kid and I'm just like,
is it weird seeing the next level coming up,
like seeing the Rory Macdonald's.
It's crazy.
It's cool.
It's good to see you.
It's wild.
It was cool because you can go to the river.
Donald come up to me or like you man,
I've been watching you since I've been like six years old and like fuck really a
battle.
Mike.
Mike McDonald.
I think he's only 21 maybe 20.
It's crazy.
It's like kids come to my gym and her train set in Huntington beach and they
their 10 year old kids who do kickboxing,
Jujitsu and they're doing an MMA classes now.
I'm just like,
are you joking?
Me and the parents are calling.
I was like,
yes.
Do you do UFC at your gym or let me,
excuse me.
You do the UFC fighting style at your gym?
You mean MMA?
Mixed martial arts?
Yes.
Do you do that?
Yes,
we do.
Are we're bringing our kid down.
It's like,
I mean I teach classes on Tuesdays and Thursdays and uh,
it's crazy.
Do the kid just like teach kids classes class?
Oh that's bad.
And so it's in Huntington beach.
Where at?
Well how can they find it?
What is the upside?
It's actually punched for training center.com punishment training center doc.
So that is also one of the fucking cool things about the sport.
It's a,
you can go and take classes your kid can from a former world champion.
Yeah.
What mean?
That's amazing to me.
It's just like I say,
I,
I've always wanted to be a coach.
Um,
I love,
I love it.
I dig it.
I love seeing the kid progress.
You know,
I remember when I first started at marina high school,
we were last in the league.
Um,
I was there for two years and when I,
when I left for a second in the lake and just to watch a kid progress and just
seeing his attitude and just how they respond to things and from the negative to
the positive and just being in an environment around them,
they're just like,
wow.
Like it's crazy if you are young boxer.
Oh beautiful.
And I painted myself nice ass place.
No,
I painted myself.
You painted that plan.
There's a floor.
See the red formal left,
the all the red flooring.
I did all the red and that's carpet on the right.
And that's all like,
Holy Shit.
That place is fucking huge.
How many squares?
She said it's actually a 10,000 square feet,
if that's what she said.
She's talking about her pussy.
Cause I said,
that place is fucking huge.
There's nothing said that.
That was huge.
Now I said that place is fine.
I think to those huge almost works.
Sound good though.
That's a massive fucking Gerrity.
Yeah,
I know.
But the color itself,
I won't,
you know,
it was red,
black,
Hawaiian.
I,
I really just kind of,
I put my heart into it,
man.
Now what I want for training and get the next level of fighters.
Of course,
you know,
we do girls kickbox and there also we do a kids wrestling kids Jujitsu.
Been Open for about two years now.
One year,
one year,
one year now.
And we're still building man.
It's to the class that,
uh,
I've really are a school that I really just tried to give for the use of that.
Jujitsu kids,
Moitai adults,
kids wrestling.
That's fucking awesome.
And it's,
the women come in and they dig it.
The women come in and do kickboxing.
It's like all of a sudden the girls,
now that's a rad thing.
The girls come in and then I want to do MMA fight and it's like,
girl,
like,
no,
but I want to do it my fine.
I don't be like really rosy contact.
Well,
you stuck to Huntington Beach House.
I ain't going no where.
You gotta understand.
I,
when I lived in Huntington,
um,
from the age of seven to 13,
I moved to Santa Ana and that was,
my parents had the drug problem.
I would be Santa Ana.
And then,
um,
I actually,
when I was 13,
my mother separate as my father and she got remarried and moved me back to
Huntington.
And um,
all the time I grew up,
all the kids lived in the Harvard heights and harbor and all the rich,
prissy kids.
And I remember fishing on one of the docs back there.
And I was like,
one day guys,
guys hold patient with my friend Dave caudal,
who's a friend of mine.
I go,
one day I'm going to buy a house here with the,
we call shut the fuck up.
That's what ever I go,
dude,
I'm serious.
One day I'm going to buy a house here.
Well we shot this bad blood.
A DVD would be in chuck.
They shot it.
And I told that story and he was with me on the bug.
And uh,
the week prior to that,
I took all my bud.
We would fish,
cause God,
do you remember that one time they were sitting with fucking doctor her pitch
for bat rays.
You told me you're gonna get a house here.
Yeah.
Fuck,
I never forgot that.
And he goes,
dude,
that is crazy shit.
But it's just one of those things.
And I'm not leaving Huntington.
I live in the harbor.
I own a fishing boat.
I now,
my kids are the ritual,
the prosecutors,
but he's not a prissy kids.
They're the rich little rich kid that,
you know,
but it's just an,
an opportunity,
you know,
I'm changing the cycle and I look at it as I worked hard to get wearing them
today.
You know what's so great about Huntington Beach?
No crime.
Crime was very,
very like,
I think it was 93.
[inaudible] 94 to 97 as the safest world in the United States.
Safest part of the United States,
the safest city in the United States.
Really?
Yes.
And uh,
but the HBP does an awesome job down there.
And then,
um,
city,
I our little town I live in or not town,
little
area that I live in.
Uh,
it's really nice.
No gangs at all.
Um,
crime is pretty much nil.
There's downtown kids get a little crazy.
Like I said,
HBP does an amazing job and I was just making sure it's very safe.
So to,
it's also like sort of a sentimental thing cause that represented the good times
in your life when you were younger and now you're back to yeah.
And you know,
um,
you know,
have h and a B behind my arms as the only tattoos I've ever had.
And uh,
forever.
You had that shit back in the day when I first met him when I was 18,
I got it.
I was the first tattoos I ever got.
Wow.
Like to beach represent.
Yeah,
it's forever.
You know,
I look at it and I don't forget where I came from.
I remember when I first became the world champion and I was in Vegas and I was
partying.
I was actually a cheetah is a strip club and uh,
I seen Diamond Dallas page there,
this when he was in WWE and I was like,
I want to get in ww one day.
And uh,
he was like,
Huh,
let me tell you one thing son,
you're the champion right now,
Ryan.
I go,
yeah,
yeah.
He goes,
I give you one word of advice.
No matter how famous you ever get,
don't ever forget where you came from.
He goes,
you'll be more successful.
You never forget where you came from.
And I always kept on shit.
This is
14 years ago.
So because of one conversation with Dallas diamond page,
you have wrapped Heineken
beach hard since then.
I have no,
I've,
I repped it no matter what.
I,
I just never forgot where I came from.
I just always been an idea in my head is is no matter how famous again went,
never,
never.
No matter how much money you make,
don't ever forget where you came from because there's guys that'll make millions
and they'll bounce.
They'll say fucking,
I forget that neighborhood.
I don't need that anymore.
That's me.
No,
I'm the first out.
As soon as I get some money,
fuck you,
don't get me wrong.
They're seniors places that I would say grab your stuff and get the fuck out of
there.
Cause there is some towns,
you know,
I mean Detroit and I mean there's,
yeah,
Santa and I mean there's,
there's places in this United States that's really hard and I advise for as
parents to get your kids out of there as soon as possible.
If you get that opportunity,
please do.
I like moving man.
Yeah,
I think it's good.
I wish I didn't have so many good friends in La.
I would like to live in a bunch of different places all over the country when
the weather's seven degrees year around.
Yeah,
there's no crime.
There's a beach and I could drive an hour and a half ago to the snow.
He also drive five hours to get to La.
The fucking Huntington beach traffic is brutal and no,
from four until seven.
Yeah.
But thank God I guy started driving a period of three 30 cause I missed all of
it.
Took me an hour.
Yeah.
Listen man,
thank you very much for doing this.
A lot of fun talking to,
you know,
it's awesome.
Anything else you want to say to these people before we were up there she goes,
I just,
you know,
I really appreciate it.
All my fans through my career,
you know,
I appreciate you doing what you've done.
You know,
this is a,
I think the fans are very appreciated for having me on here.
I am of course,
you know,
and thank for Lorenzo Fertitta,
Dana White,
um,
frank Fertitta for saving the UFC and giving me an opportunity to give my family
what I've always wanted.
That's just being a loving father and to give them things that I'd never had as
a kid.
And that's loving.
Well
Tito or Ortiz bitches.
And congratulations on a fantastic career and good luck in the future.
And,
uh,
I know whatever energy that you put into becoming a champion you put into
anything else you choose to focus on,
you still a young man,
man.
You're crazy.
You've got a crazy opportunity.
You got a whole new life now.
Yeah.
Holding.
I'm excited.
People say retirement.
It's not retirement.
I'm just graduating from fighting.
I'm going on.
And they retired.
They're old man.
You're a young dude.
Some fucking crazy parts.
Some bionic parts.
Yeah,
no,
I got some good stuff coming up.
I got some,
some shows I'm doing working on that with possibly with the NBC.
So good.
Well,
keep us posted man.
And if he ever needed anything promoted,
come on back,
man.
I'll for sure.
Let me know.
We'll blow it up on Twitter before the year's over for sure that I'm going to do
that.
Okay.
And Huntington Beach Training Center.
Uh,
punishment,
athletics,
training centers.
Yes.
And then punish mathletics question.
My clothing company,
of course,
punishment,
nutrition.
Ladies and gentleman,
if you want to get some fucking classes from Tito Ortiz himself.
Yes.
Oh,
awesome.
What days,
what days are you teaching there?
They Thursdays,
Tuesdays and Thursdays.
Go on down.
Check it out bitches and thanks to uh,
on at Dotcom for sponsors but tanks,
the Alienware MMA to cause a alien where uh,
we've been using these computers you have for a couple of months now.
They stay hooked us up with them and we're supporting them because they support
fighters and then where I need some stuff hooked Tito Ortiz up,
Tito Ortiz up pitches,
but Alienware sponsors a lot of up and coming fighters and so we support them.
Uh,
if you follow them on Twitter,
it's alien MMA on Twitter.
Just show him some love.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm doing this right now.
Let's do this.
Let's do it.
Alright,
thanks to ana.com.
Uh,
if you're down with some Alpha brain shroom tech sport,
shroom tech,
amu new mood or bone strong user code named Brogan,
the save yourself 10% off.
Also check out the kettlebells we got going on now and battle ropes,
all different sorts of sizes and packages for Kettlebells,
beginners and experts and a for battle ropes.
The battle ropes are there.
It's all completely new.
The cheapest shit you're going to find on the Internet,
the best quality.
It's all at [inaudible] dot com.
That's o.
N.
I.
T.
All right,
we'll see you freaks on Thursday with a,
the great Tom Rhodes.
Great,
hilarious,
awesome real international comedian and world traveler.
And he's going to be here on Thursday.
She'd be a lot of fucking fun and awesome test squad
tomorrow.
Joe Rogan,
Dom Arrera.
Uh,
we got a possible Doug Benson,
he,
uh,
Brody Stevens,
Ian Edwards,
Christina Presensky,
and a policy
[inaudible].
Oh,
that's a beautiful lineup in Edwards if you've never seen it before.
It's fucking hilarious.
And of course Dama rare all time.
Great.
So we'll see dirty bitches on Wednesday.
That's even before this tomorrow.
Yeah.
Tomorrow at the Ice House.
There's some tickets still available.
We just announced it today.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
go to ice house comedy.com and get your tickets,
dirty freaks and the ice house chronicles podcast that we air simultaneously.
How revolutionary is this,
Ladies and gentlemen?
We have a fucking podcast that we do while we're doing a comedy show.
The green room of standup Comedians,
a standup comedy clubs rather.
It's always been the most fun for standup comedians.
It's a place where we fuck around before we go on stage,
everybody's laughing and joking around and,
but we decided to do was turn that into a podcast.
So it's called the ice house chronicles,
and it's only available through the death squad label on iTunes.
So go check that out.
And support desk squad.tv dirty bitches.
All right,
we'll see you soon.
See You tomorrow.
Nice.
I tell chronicles available,
I'm this Ustream channel,
Ustream.
Dot.
TV Ford Slash Joe Rogan.
All right.
Yeah.